(upbeat music)
So, my approach with nutrition science
has always been to let the science do the talking
and be led by the data or be open to changing your mind.
(upbeat music)
Very few topics are more hotly debated than nutrition.
It truly is right up there with politics and religion,
but the irony is that in terms of the optimal diet
that considers both human and planetary health,
the hard science is actually quite clear that we should
and actually must be moving towards a diet
that is as plant-exclusive as possible.
Nonetheless, misinformation persists,
confusing and paralyzing the average well-intentioned person
which can and often does lead to avoidable disease.
To help us today parse facts from fiction
and guide us towards a reasoned, rational model
for nutritional health and well-being,
we convene with my friend, Simon Hill.
Simon is the host of the fantastic Plant Proof Podcast
and blog of the same name,
both absolutely incredible resources
and he plies his master's degree in nutrition
to objectively decipher the scientific literature
to help people make better diet and lifestyle choices
to promote optimal health and longevity.
Simon is also the plant-based food contributor
to Chris Hemsworth's fitness app center
and he's the author of this fantastic new book,
"The Proof Is In The Plants"
which is a phenomenal, evidence-based primer
on the positive impact of a plant-predominant diet.
We have all the hot topics today, tribal diet wars,
what the science says, what it doesn't,
the environmental implications of our food choices,
the truth about saturated fat, cholesterol and seed oils
and the key things you can and should be doing right now
to perform at your peak, sidestep disease,
promote longevity and live both optimally and consciously.
For so many reasons,
Simon is the health and nutrition resource
we all need right now and this one is packed with crucial,
perhaps even life-saving information,
including links that Simon has provided to all the studies
that he references throughout the conversation,
which you can find in the show notes on the episode page
at richroll.com.
So, with that being said,
please enjoy my conversation with Simon Hill.
Mate, how long have we talked about doing this?
It's been a long time.
It has been a long time, years in fact.
I know, it's--
I was in Australia,
I was tempted to do it with you then,
I've been on your show a bunch of times,
we've been friends for a couple of years at this point.
I think I reached out to you to do this earlier,
but you kinda wanted to sit on it
until your book was coming out.
So, we waited, here we are.
You're in Los Angeles.
Good to see you my friend.
Thank you, likewise.
It's buddy awesome to be here, let me tell you that.
It's been a long time coming, you're right,
but I think it's nice timing with the book coming out.
Yeah, absolutely, man and I'm excited to get into the book
and everything like that,
but just sort of a prefatory way of contextualizing this,
the thing that I...
Besides our friendship,
the thing that I really appreciate about you the most
is your very kind of grounded, rational,
non-absolutist approach to nutrition.
Everything that you talk about and advocate is objective,
it's evidence-based, you're not driven by ideology,
you're calm in your delivery,
you have experience in education and nutrition,
you're not hyperbolic
and your analysis of nutrition science
is always deeply-rooted in the studies
and your advocacy is oriented around actionable,
doable changes that people can make
and you deliver all of this in a non-judgmental
and very even keeled approach,
which I think is something that we not only need right now,
but I think we're thirsting for
in a kind of social media landscape at least
that tilts towards extremism and hyperbolic narratives.
Well, that means a lot to me
because I think I pride myself
on trying to communicate the science
as objectively as possible.
And I'm a big believer in science
and how science can help us better understand the world
and better navigate it and improve our lives,
but you're right.
I think a lot of the nuanced conversation has been lost
and some of that is a result of social media
and the algorithms that are at play
and the absolute message is often favored
from an engagement point of view.
It will reinforce one's identity
and at the same time perhaps challenge
and trigger the other side's identity,
which is the ultimate result
if you're looking to create engagement and excitement.
So, ever since I was a little kid,
I have had a deep appreciation for science
and being able to use it as a tool
to help reduce the amount of uncertainty
and that's what science is.
It's using a method to test our intuition, our hypotheses
and to reduce that uncertainty
so we can make decisions with more confidence.
And so my approach with nutrition science
has always been to let the science do the talking
and be led by the data or be open to changing your mind
and a lot of that I've really learnt from my dad.
Your dad was a scientist, a medical doctor, yeah
and you have this kind of evolution story
of how you got into nutrition science
that really begins with a health crisis
that was faced by your dad.
Yeah, when I was maybe three or four years old,
that's sort of as far back as my memory goes, maybe five.
As early as I can recall,
I would be surrounded by scientific papers,
my dad would print these things out
and they would fill up the coffee table
and if he picked me up from school,
I'd have to lift them up off the car seat
just to get into the car and they'd always be highlighted
and I couldn't make much sense of them,
but I could see how important science was to my dad
and the work that he was doing.
He got his PhD in Texas so we moved as a family to Texas
where he did his PhD in physiology
and has gone on since then
to have 30 or 40 years of academic research as a professor
and publishing in circulation
and metabolism-leading journals
and a very well-respected professor
in his field of physiology,
which is looking right under a microscope
at the micro level mechanisms, deep science,
much deeper than what I do.
I tend to zoom out and think about what's the big picture,
what does this mean to you and I?
How can we make better decisions and be healthier
and how can we consider the world around us?
But his research equally as important,
understanding the mechanisms that are at play
has been dedicated to looking at how our arteries function
and dysfunction
and what happens when you develop type 2 diabetes
and cardiovascular disease.
And this is somewhat ironic because you're right,
I did experience for the first time
what loss of health looks like and on weekends,
my dad and my brother...
You've met my brother a couple years ago here in LA, James
and he's actually the one that introduced me
to your show originally.
On weekends when we had moved back to Australia...
So, when I was about 10 years old
and my dad had finished his PhD
and was working as an assistant professor in America,
we moved back to Australia.
And on weekends we would go
and explore an area called the Yarra Valley.
And it's a beautiful wine district in Victoria,
rolling hills, incredible scenery and we would go
and visit little wineries,
my dad always liked to choose the small ones.
And if you went to these more boutique wineries
and this wasn't about the alcohol,
it was about the experience.
And you could speak to the winemaker usually
and you could see the passion they had
for what they were doing.
And so we would have a lot of fun together
exploring these areas and on this one particular day,
it was just my dad and I,
we had a fantastic day out together
and my dad had a MGB Convertible,
I can remember these days vividly.
My dad had an MG Midget so I know the vibe.
Great, great cars and the roof would come down
and we would play classics like "You Too"
and "Rolling Stones" and Cat Stevens
and all that sort of stuff
and I think a lot of people listening
perhaps can relate to that
perhaps with experiences with their parents or uncle
or someone in their life those days you look back on,
20, 30 years ago and with very sort of fond memories.
These were those days for me.
And on this one day in particular
as we're driving home, it's dusk,
I could see that my dad was uncomfortable
and he was slightly grimacing
and he was also rubbing his chest.
And I asked him if everything was okay
and he said he was feeling some chest pain,
but downplayed it
and we continued to go home and cooked dinner
and I remember checking in again
and he said that everything was fine.
So, we had dinner and thinking nothing of it,
I went off to bed.
And a short while afterwards,
I woke to some noise in the kitchen
and I thought,
"Well, thinking about what had happened,
I better go and check if he's okay."
And when I went out,
I could see he was making his way to the phone,
he had the phone in his hand by that stage
and he was on his knees, at this stage, this was, Rich,
the first time that I've ever seen my dad with so much fear
in his eyes.
It was a point now that he could no longer deny
what was happening.
And he was pale, he was out of breath
and it was very obvious that he was struggling.
And so I actually spoke with the lady
on the other end of the line, hit code triple zero,
which is like calling 911 here
and I was explaining what was happening
and all of this was happening super quickly
and I was 15 at the time, my dad was 41,
this was out of nowhere.
He was not reliant on the healthcare system,
he had no medical diagnosis,
he was not taking any medications,
he was living the standard Australian lifestyle.
And if you looked at my dad at that stage,
you would not look at him
and say he is particularly unhealthy.
He was in decent shape and would exercise
and for all intents and purposes
was just representative of young, Australian dad.
And studying vascular physiology at the time.
Right, so many years later
and now a better understanding what happened
and the disease at play, which I'll go into,
it's become clear to me
that my dad knew exactly what was happening at the time.
And I think this denial is quite common
particularly in males that are experiencing poor health
perhaps if you deny what you're feeling it will go away.
I'm not sure it works like that.
I have some familiarity with that.
So, the lady on the other end of the line
after me explaining what was happening said,
"We need to send a helicopter."
And so where we were at that point in time,
my dad had a place in Kinglake so my parents were separated,
when we moved back they got divorced,
when we moved back to Australia
and my mom and my brother and I
we were actually living in Melbourne
and then we would spend the weekends with dad.
So, they said, "We need to send a helicopter,"
Kinglake is quite remote,
there was like this mud brick house
in the middle of nowhere.
My dad's always loved being out in the middle of nowhere
and then any way
it was a long way from the nearest hospital.
So, they sent a helicopter and it came so quickly
and they rushed in and scooped him up,
put him onto a stretcher and put him on oxygen
and were checking his vital signs and before I knew it,
he was in the helicopter and it was flying off
and I couldn't fit in the helicopter so they said to me
I could follow in a car, in an ambulance to the hospital.
And by that time, I called my mother and my brother
and said, "You probably should come to the hospital.
This is what's happening.
I don't know what the outcome is here,
we really don't know the specifics,
but dad's not in a good way."
And that car ride to the hospital
it felt like it took forever and we got to the hospital
and we waited and we waited and the doctor came out
and said to us,
"we've saved your father's life.
He's had a severe heart attack,"
which of course the fact they saved his life
was what we were most concerned about then and there,
but we were very shocked that at 41,
this had come out of nowhere.
And the next day, there was a family meeting
as there often is, it's a bit of a debrief, what's happened,
what's the prognosis, et cetera
and so we met with the cardiologist
and he had taken my dad's history
and it was quite clear that cardiovascular disease
does run in my family.
And my grandfather had had a heart attack
at about age 61 I believe, my grandmother...
So, that was my dad's dad, my dad's mom, my grandmother,
she had vascular dementia
and so the cardiologist said to my brother...
My brother was 18, I was 15,
he said that, "Cardiovascular disease runs in families,
clearly it's running in yours
and this will be something that you need to be screened for
as you get older."
And looking back on that today, that is great advice.
But the conversation ended there and--
It lacks any sense of agency, this is a predestined thing,
this is genetically motivated
and you're gonna have to contend with it at some point
and that's very much of that time as well.
Like we know a lot more now about how we can intervene
and make these lifestyle choices,
but I was told the same thing.
My grandfather died early, like I know that whole drill
and what it leaves you with
and you tell me how you felt was this sense
that there really isn't much you can do about it.
Yeah, you've been dealt a bad card.
I mean, that is how I felt
and my brother felt for many years,
was that what's to say we're not going to follow
in my dad's footsteps?
He was living a typical Australian lifestyle,
he wasn't from the outside unhealthy
and this has happened to him,
so why will it be any different for us?
If you do the same thing as everyone around you,
how can you expect different results?
So, it's disempowering when you get that news
and you put your health down purely to genetics.
And it was many years later that I would come to learn that
while genetics do create predispositions
and can increase your likelihood
of developing a certain disease, your lifestyle
and the way that you're navigating your life
has a lot more say.
And there are a bunch of studies
looking at identical twins for example,
the exact same genes, different environments growing up,
nature versus nurture, what happens?
And these studies have been able to tease out
what is the impact of genetics
versus lifestyle broadly speaking
and of course this is different
depending on the type of genes that someone has,
but broadly speaking,
if we're thinking about these big chronic diseases
like cardiovascular disease, type 2 diabetes,
fatty liver disease, even Alzheimer's dementia,
broadly speaking, your genes are controlling about 20%
of your health fate.
And that means that your environment
and your lifestyle is controlling 80%,
is four times more powerful
and so of course when you come across that information
then the game changes, the narrative flips
from being disempowered to being incredibly empowered.
So, is your brother...
Correct me if I'm wrong, who was the first instigator
in terms of getting you interested in nutrition?
You've done your research.
A little bit.
I know you two, so it's not like, yeah.
I didn't expect any less.
So, when I finished high school,
I actually wanted to become a doctor.
And I got really, really strong grades at school,
but not quite strong enough
to get into medicine in Melbourne.
And so I was accepted to do medicine, but in Tasmania
and I wasn't quite prepared
to make the move down to Tasmania and give up my friendships
and give up playing football
and so I made the decision to stick around
and I did physiotherapy instead in Melbourne.
And the reason I tell you this
is because I was very much indoctrinated
and I was surrounded by this fitness culture,
I was working in football club environments
and these are environments where animal protein is king.
And so there was a Christmas
where my brother was coming up to stay with me
with his fiancee at the time, Lauren who's now his wife
and he called me up and he said,
"We've been reading and listening to a few things,"
probably your podcast
and probably some of Dan Buettner's work I believe
and he had come across some information
to suggest that there were populations
that were not experiencing the same levels,
the same degree of cardiovascular disease
that our societies experience.
And of course thinking back to our dad's history
and grandfather's history, that was meaningful information
for my brother to come across
and enough for him to want to explore
and he's from a business background
so it was not something that was inspiring him to get deep
into the science or the weights with,
he felt that the information was of high enough quality
to act on.
And he called me to say,
"Lauren and I have changed the way we're eating a bit"
and it was a bit of a heads-up.
They were coming to stay with me
and I was going to do some grocery shopping of course
and take them out for dinner and he said,
"We're no longer eating red meat and chicken,
we've adopted a pescatarian diet."
I think this might have been like my introduction
to dietary labels.
Before then, I hadn't given a whole lot of thought
to all the different dietary labels that exist
or the dietary wars,
I was just doing what I knew.
And I said to him, "Well, that's cool.
I eat fish and we can make that work
and I'm sure we can find restaurants
that will cater for that."
And that was a few months before him coming up
and then about a week before he came up,
he called me up again and he said,
"We've changed our diet a little more."
(both laugh)
The volume is getting turned up.
Yeah and I thought, "Okay," I thought maybe he'd reverted
and he said, "Well, we've decided to remove the fish."
And I was thinking, "What the fuck is left?"
How long ago was this?
This is 2014, '15.
Not that long ago.
Yeah, 2014, '15 and so I said to him, I said,
"Look, well, I'm definitely going to need some help
with regards to knowing what to buy
and certainly with restaurants."
I had no business in choosing the restaurants
that would be catering for vegan meals, to be honest,
I had never really considered a diet
without animal products.
And he came up and both he and Lauren are great cooks
and particularly Lauren and so they did a lot of cooking
and we went out to some restaurants
and the feeling that I was left with
at the end of those two weeks
was no any pressure from them,
they weren't asking me to consider how I was eating,
we just had a great two weeks together
and their food was delicious
and so the feeling that I was left with was,
"Well, if my brother's right
and there is some information out there
that suggests you can change the way you're eating
and reduce your risk of cardiovascular disease
and I know that I don't have to sacrifice on flavor and joy
and the experience,
then this is something that I should be looking into."
But for those that aren't watching on YouTube
and are just listening,
what you might not know is that
Simon is a physical specimen,
like you're a buffed, big strong guy
and you were working with Australian rules football guys
at the time, like your focus is on performance and strength
and agility and all of these things.
So, how does that information mesh with everything
that you knew up to that point and were interested in
because, "Yes, oh, I feel good and this tastes good,
but how is this going to fuel me
and keep me in the physical condition
to which I'm accustomed?"
So, I had that fear completely.
I think the first step for me
was first looking at the information and science
around chronic disease.
And then when I had unearthed information there
and it became clear to me
that there was a way to eat
to reduce your risk of chronic disease, the next step was,
"Am I going to have to sacrifice
the physical performance, athletic pursuits?
Am I going to be able to maintain,
improve strength, et cetera?"
And so the first step, Rich for me after that was...
I was trained in physiotherapy initially, remember,
at this time I actually hadn't done my master's
in nutrition science.
That's been done in the last seven years.
So, when my brother came and stayed with me
and inspired me to think about this,
I had no formal training in nutrition.
I had done an undergraduate degree in physiotherapy,
which is a four-year sort of bachelor in science,
so you cover a lot of physiology and anatomy
and I did an honors year where I wrote my own thesis,
performed the review, conducted my own study
and wrote it up.
So, I understood how to look at research and analyze it
albeit from a different lens, a different area of science.
So, the first step for me was to try
and get into the literature
and see if what my brother was telling me was true or not.
And I quite often say I wanted to prove him wrong.
I was healthy, I wasn't having any health issues,
I was strong, I was fit,
everything about my diet seemed to be working for me,
not against me.
And as I was getting into the research initially,
what I realized was how many polarizing views there are
and how confusing it is and tribal.
And one moment I thought I understood something
then I'd say the exact opposite.
And that's what inspired me to go
and do the master's in nutrition science
because I realized even though I had training
at an undergraduate level in science,
I was not equipped with the skills to make full sense of it
and to really decode it.
And so it was back to university
and to really focusing on the research base side of things
and then get right down into the weeds
of the nutrition science to try and understand
exactly what an optimal diet looks like,
So, you get your master's in nutrition science,
there's a whole like sort of backstory or backdrop here,
this entrepreneurial journey that you've been on
that's almost its own podcast,
we can maybe revisit that a little bit,
but you emerge from that experience,
you become steeped in the science,
you have this kind of urgent call to advocacy
that leads you to create plant proof.com
and the Plant Proof Podcast
and the latest iteration now being this new book,
"The Proof Is In The Plants",
but walk me through how you arrived
at a certain kind of global thesis around nutrition
and perhaps state that case.
So, I guess the thesis to start here with the thesis
and then I can go into how I came to that
and how I look at science in general,
the thesis is that there is a set of characteristics
or a theme that define an optimal diet
rather than one particular dietary brand
being absolutely proven by science as the most optimal.
And this theme is that diets that are low in saturated fat,
that provide good amounts of unsaturated fat,
that are rich in fiber,
that have a good amount of plant protein
and are low in ultra-processed foods,
time and time again lead to good health outcomes.
These are the people
that are experiencing less cardiovascular disease,
less likelihood of having a heart attack or a stroke,
less risk of developing type 2 diabetes,
less risk of fatty liver disease,
less risk of various cancers
and less risk of neurodegenerative diseases.
And the cool thing I guess about that theme
is that there are many variations of that.
That could be a really thoughtfully constructed
Mediterranean diet,
Mediterranean diet as described by Ancel Keys
who was a very prominent scientist in the mid 1900s,
he described that as a largely vegetarian diet.
It does include some animal products,
but they're not as emphasized
as a standard Western diet today.
It could be a really well-done pescetarian diet,
it could be a really well-done vegetarian diet,
it could be a completely plant-exclusive, whole food,
plant-based diet.
And so it means that there are lots of ways
to sort of eat your way to good health.
And that's a sort of less absolute message
and perhaps not as sexy--
Yeah, that makes it difficult,
you can't come up with a label for this
or some kind of contrite, specific, drill down term
that allows it to trend on Twitter
and create a simplified idea
that can get lodged in someone's brain.
But that's science.
That's science
and the way I like to kind of describe this to people
is that any of those diets,
if you compare them to a standard diet
and there are a bunch of studies that have done those,
you'll see significant risk reductions for various diseases.
But if you were to run
let's say a randomized controlled trial from birth
and just include those dietary patterns
that I just mentioned,
which are all sort of very thoughtfully constructed diets
and you would follow those people across their lifespan,
you're unlikely to see any difference in outcomes
because all of those diets are so significantly different
to the standard Western diet,
which is the diet that is provoking disease the most.
So, how do I look at science
and sort of come to that conclusion?
A few different principles kind of guide the work I guess
that I do
and when you understand these principles,
it also makes social media
and the headlines a little frustrating.
But I guess firstly, not all science is equal.
Right, so we could talk about the hierarchy of science.
We hear terms like randomized controlled trials,
population studies, epidemiological studies, all of that
and perhaps we have some familiarity with what those mean,
but walk us through that hierarchy
and how we parse fact from fiction
when it comes to evaluating the multitude of studies
that are out there among which you can find a study
or cherry-pick this or that
that's going to affirm your thesis.
So, yeah, the evidence hierarchy allows us
to kind of add weight to certain evidence
based on how reliable and valid it is.
And at the very bottom,
which is the sort of least reliable
and least valid evidence is expert opinion.
If I just say something without a citation,
someone, a professor or a doctor just says something,
that's considered very weak evidence.
Just above that is laboratory studies.
These are in vitro studies
looking at cells under a microscope or animal studies
and it's not to say that this science is not important.
It can be an important part of piecing together the puzzle.
But it's hypothesis-generating.
The idea that a certain metabolic pathway in a mouse
that you could extrapolate
to how that applies to human health is tenuous the best.
Yeah and we see time and time again lectins or soy
and a lot of people generating fear about these
and they are arriving at that conclusion
based on this sort of in vitro animal-based study
and overlooking the human health outcome data,
which really is a more valid source of information
for public health recommendations.
It's interesting to see what happens in a cell or an animal,
but we also then have to zoom out
and see what happens in a human.
And also you can fall into some traps with research
in an animal or in vitro
where the exposure level is very important.
For example you could...
If you're looking at phytoestrogens in soy for example,
you could look in an animal model
and show estrogenic effects
and then perhaps that could get you worried
about the development of hormone-dependent cancers
like prostate and breast cancer.
But what a lot of those studies have looked at
if you were to look at the exposure level
on a per kilograms of those phytoestrogens,
per kilogram of body mass or pound of body mass,
what you would see is that the exposure level
in that rat is magnitudes higher
than the exposure level
that any human would ever be exposed to
through eating soy or tempeh, et cetera.
So, not only is physiology different at the animal level
between an animal and a human,
but also sometimes exposure can be significantly different.
So, that's I guess the sort of level above expert opinion
and I think something else that is probably useful here
is Fleming discovered penicillin
and I think that was back in 1936 or something.
Yeah, mid 30s.
Yeah and he discovered that through...
Started in a petri dish that he'd left out
and he saw that this mold was destroying the bacterial cells
and then by studying the mold,
he was able to isolate penicillin.
And then he was able to use penicillin effectively in rats
as an antibiotic
and then was able to do it again in humans
and that kind of progression,
that progression is actually very rare.
You might have 50, 100,000 discoveries in a rat
that don't play out in human for every one that does.
So, we hear of these success stories
like Fleming and penicillin and we think,
"Well, the animal model is a great model with sound,"
but what we don't hear of is how often it fails.
So, I think it's just an important reminder
that it is a hypothesis-generating level of science
and really we shouldn't
be making public health recommendations
from that level of science alone
unless there is zero human outcome data
and you wanna take a sort of precautionary stance.
So, then the rank above that
is observational science, epidemiology.
And there are a bunch of different types
of observational study designs,
but the key point here is you're looking at humans
that live in a population
and you're observing the way they live.
In the case of nutrition, you're looking at what they eat
or don't eat and you're looking at specific health outcomes
and you're trying to see
if you can find any sort of tight associations.
These people that are eating more of this
end up having a higher risk of this.
For example, people that are eating
more ultra processed meats
have around 18% higher risk of colorectal cancer
per 50 grams consumed per day.
And it's not a perfect science, but no science is
and I think often observational science gets slammed
by certain folks out there
and one of the common sort of criticisms
is that there is a healthy user effect.
And that is that if you're looking at populations of people
who are eating more fruits and vegetables
and you're looking at health outcomes be it cancer
or cardiovascular disease,
perhaps it's not the fact that
they're eating fruits and vegetables,
but that that's a sign that they live a healthy life.
Sure, there's all these co-founding variables
and the Achilles heel
being that when you're in this observational modality,
you can't control for any of those variables,
people are just living their lives.
So, there's also the risk of life misreporting as well
because it's based on people reporting what they're eating
and how they're living on some level.
So, are people actually writing down
what they're really doing
or are they writing down what they think you wanna hear?
There's room for all kinds of error, but at the same time,
if you're taking massive populations of people,
you can extrapolate from that some general trends
and there is some level of reliability
with what you're observing.
It's just limited
in terms of what you can extrapolate from that.
Yeah, you can't create a sort of cause
and effect conclusion,
you can't say that variable A is causing this outcome.
So, you can only speak to associations,
but I think something that's really important here is that
the researchers are aware
of the limitations of this study design
and so the confounding variables for example,
although you might not be able
to remove their complete effect,
they do through statistics control for them.
So, the idea is
if you have a really well-defined population
that you are as best as possible working out
how often people drink alcohol, how often they smoke,
how often they exercise and in your analysis,
let's say for example you wanna look at the fiber's effect
on a certain health outcome.
The idea with controlling for confounding variables is that
we're not going to compare people
that have significantly different consumption of alcohol.
What we're going to do is compare high and low fiber
between people who are exposed
to the same amount of alcohol.
So, that's the idea through adjustment
is to remove some of the effect
of these confounding variables,
so there is a statistical protocol
called multivariate analysis
and the researchers use this to the best of their ability.
When it comes to the food frequency questionnaires,
they do have their limitations,
but they also validate them in that population too
if it's a good study, that's what they should be doing.
They have tools
to validate that food frequency questionnaire,
which means going out and performing a study
to make sure that as you say,
what people are reporting is reliable
and there are methods of doing that.
So, it's sort of they're not just going out
and completely shooting in the dark,
there are steps and processes within epidemiology
to produce good epidemiology
and of course they can be bad epidemiology as well.
And then above that, what's the next tier up?
So, above that is your randomized controlled trials,
these are clinical interventions
and the idea here is that by having a clinical intervention,
you can remove the effect of other variables
other than what you're looking at.
So, it's very controlled,
perhaps you have two different groups
and the only difference between those two groups
is the exposure that you're looking at.
Maybe it is for example the addition of fiber to a diet
or the addition of a certain vegetable oil.
And therefore you can have a greater degree of confidence
that the outcome that you're measuring
is a result of the difference between those two variables.
The cause and effect.
Yeah.
And then above that, we have these meta analyses.
Like where you take all of these studies
that are of a certain ilk and lump them into one pile
and kind of compare and contrast all of them
to draw even deeper conclusions.
Yeah, so the idea is
if you pull together 30 randomized controlled trials
from around the world
that are all looking at the same thing
from different researchers in different labs
and you pull them together and perform an analysis,
you're likely to reduce the chance of any bias
that could be affecting any individual study.
That said, a meta analysis is also...
There are times where a meta analysis
can be performed poorly,
it has to define what its inclusion criteria is
and therefore what studies it includes
and if you put garbage in you're going to get garbage out.
So, meta analysis again is not bulletproof,
you still have to be able to look at it,
understand what the inclusion and exclusion criteria was
and then look at the results
in the context of everything else
and that's the key here is that
when you're reviewing the science
and you're looking at any individual study,
you then have to step back out
and look at the totality of the evidence.
Ideally what we're looking for is converging lines,
the mechanistic studies under the microscope
and in the animals are pointing in the same direction
as what the epidemiology is pointing in,
is pointing in the same direction
as what the clinical intervention studies are.
I think this is all really important.
I mean, the reason I wanted to dive
into this hierarchy of evidence
is simply because I think it's important
that people develop
some level of evidentiary literacy around this
particularly when people are going online
and they're reading stuff on Facebook or Twitter
and somebody is promoting a certain diet or lifestyle
and they're using study X, Y or Z
as evidentiary proof of this,
it's important to understand,
"Well, what kind of study was that?
What are the circumstances
under which it was conducted, et cetera"
and what you see
with respect to the tribalism that abounds
is a certain group...
And this cuts across every dietary tribe,
like they will throw an epidemiological study under the bus
because that's trash,
but then they'll cite one that supports their perspective
and there's this kind of war of ideas that goes on
where shots are fired across the bow at each other
and for the average consumer, it's like,
"I'm not reading these studies.
I'm not going on NBCI
and like trying to figure all this stuff out."
And it's really hard to find somebody
who's coming from an objective point of view
to help people parse all of this out
and I feel like you're a good actor in this space,
somebody who's willing to admit when they're wrong,
who's teachable, who's learning as we go,
sharing what you're finding along the way,
calling out BS when you see it
and that's a real public service.
There's a lot of false equivalence
is how I like to describe it
where on social media, every one now if you read the blog
or the posts on social, the first two words, study show
and yeah how can studies show such contradictory positions
and how can such contradictory positions exist?
So, it's frustrating and I can see
from someone who's just trying to make sense of things
that it's incredibly difficult
and I think many people are left with this idea
that science isn't settled,
science doesn't understand what a healthy diet is
looking at all these different opinions that are out there
and then when you're in that position,
it's very easy to kind of just throw your hands up
in the air and stick with what you know
and where you're comfortable.
So, I do think it's important
for people to understand this evidence hierarchy,
but equally speaking,
I think something that I've also sort of grown to learn
over time in trying to communicate this message
is not to expect too much from the average person
trying to make sense of this.
And what I mean by that is people are busy,
they have their own careers, their own jobs
and they're not like me sitting down
and reading nutrition science papers
seven, eight hours a day and geeking out on them.
And that's cool,
they've got their own passions and interests.
And we hear this kind of throwaway line
of do your own research or I did my research
and I kind of laugh sometimes when I hear that,
I mean, really doing your own research
if you think about that phrase literally
it would mean going and getting trained in a bachelor's
and then becoming a professor and having a research question
and then raising grant money and performing the research
and hiring the statisticians...
I always fumble that word
and the research assistants and performing the research
or it could be someone
who's maybe not performing the research themselves,
but is trained to read it and to get into the study
and understand exactly what they're looking at.
And to look at the exposure that I spoke about before
compared to what
if we're looking at a certain food or nutrient
and we're looking at an outcome,
what are we comparing it to?
Such an important question that's often overlooked,
understanding the evidence hierarchy, being able to zoom out
and think about the totality of the evidence,
all of this stuff,
I think it's a big ask to us the average person
to be doing that on the regular to make sense of things
and this is where I think these consensus guideline papers
from the American College of Cardiology
or the American College of Endocrinology
or the American Cancer Society,
these guideline papers are,
they are those people
who are conducting the research themselves,
who are trained to read the research
to understand the totality of the evidence
and then provide recommendations.
And so when I see someone say, "Do your own research"
to someone, I think that it's a little unfair
and I think in many ways,
what's more constructive is to point them to a good resource
where there are very credible, experienced people
that have been engaged to do exactly that.
Do your own research often means
I found the guy who I like and I resonate with him
and I find him to be credible and believable.
Yes.
On some level, there's a leap of faith
and a level of trust
that that person is telling me the straight truth.
And the less aware you are I guess
of the way that science works,
I think the more effected you can be by confirmation bias.
And so it can be easy to just go
and find the information that reinforces your current views,
established views, your identity
and at the same time turn a blind eye
to anything that perhaps challenges that
and so I think that right now,
I empathize with the average person
trying to make sense of what on earth to eat
and people are terribly confused
and caught in the middle of all this.
So, as somebody who has quote, unquote, done the research,
like you're a guy who's done the research,
you've looked at the totality of evidence,
you've extrapolated from that
to develop this thesis that you spoke about earlier,
which on some level I feel could be said
in more simple terms to be a plant-predominant diet,
perhaps not a plant-exclusive diet, although that's great,
but a diet that leans in towards mostly plants.
Is that fair?
That's fair.
So, a plant-predominant to a plant-exclusive diet
and why does this work?
Well, there's a two-fold kind of effect going on here.
You're reducing your exposure to certain foods and nutrients
that we know when consumed in excess will promote disease.
Things like saturated fat for example
that are the most common source of saturated fats
is in animal foods,
you're reducing your exposure
to certain carcinogenic compounds,
you're at the same time reducing your exposure
to ultra-processed foods,
let's not forget that in this country,
60% of the average person's calories
come from ultra-processed foods.
And in Australia, it's nearly 50% and similar in the UK
and in Canada.
And we know from clinical intervention studies
and we could go into that if you want to explore it
that these ultra-processed foods are hyperpalatable,
they make it super easy to overconsume calories.
They promote hedonic hunger
where we're consuming calories
in the absence of a physiological requirement
and they're designed by food scientists to do that,
to hit the bliss point
and they've done a good job
if you look at the consumption levels,
so we're reducing our exposure to certain parts of a diet
that are promoting poor health and then at the same time
we're increasing our exposure to fiber.
And fiber is probably the most overlooked nutrient.
If there was one thing that I was going to say to people
to focus on that would just straighten up their diet
and would reduce their risk of so many of these diseases
and help them live healthier for longer,
it would be to get more fiber into their diet.
And I know you've had our mutual friend, Dr. B--
Yeah, at your insistence earlier,
you were the guy who was like,
"You gotta check this dude out"
and then I had him on of course he's a rockstar.
He's been on your show many times,
he wrote the foreword to your book.
He wrote the foreword and the microbiome is wild
and in many ways what's going on in our microbiome
and the loss of biodiversity reflects the macro world.
And it's no coincidence that farming
and food production is affecting both.
So, the introduction of more fiber to the diet is crucial
for nourishing the microbiome,
for creating a healthy balance of the 38 trillion microbes
that call your large intestine their home.
And when you are nourishing them and feeding them,
they reward you.
And so that's obviously an extremely important benefit
of increasing these plant foods in the diet,
you're also increasing the amount of plant protein
in your diet and we see very, very consistently
in large observational studies
that look at substitution analyses
what happens when you reduce animal protein
in someone's diet and increase plant protein.
And we see dramatic reductions
in the risk of all of these chronic diseases,
we see reductions in total mortality,
the risk of premature death.
So, that's a huge benefit.
And perhaps one of the most important benefits
is the exposure to all of these phytochemicals
and there are 5, 10, 20,000 plus phytochemicals.
We haven't even yet identified all of them.
And you've probably heard a lot about polyphenols
and people probably immediately think of resveratrol
in red wine or chlorogenic acids in coffee
or curcumin in turmeric or catechins in green tea.
These polyphenol compounds,
while not essential nutrients...
And when I say not essential nutrients,
they are not essential for your survival,
but they are essential for promoting optimal health.
And we know just through work in the last 10 years
that most of the polyphenols you eat
actually pass through your small intestine,
they land in your large intestine
and it's the microbiome,
it's the bacteria that metabolize them
and produce 1000s of metabolites
that have downstream effects through the body
that are driving down inflammation
both systemically, also in the central nervous system
and so as we're making these changes to our diet
and eating in this more plant-predominant pattern,
this way of eating that the Blue Zones aid,
Okinawans in Japan, the Sardinians,
the folks in Loma Linda
who on average are living around 10 years longer
than the standard American,
we are producing the risk of these diseases
through a range of risk factors that we're modifying.
That's the key part here.
By driving down cholesterol, by driving down blood pressure,
by improving our insulin resistance, all of this stuff
along with an anti-inflammatory diet
that is helping promote a more robust immune system
is creating a healthier body.
So, it's multi-factored
in the sense that moving towards
a more plant-predominant diet,
you're crowding out space for some of those foods
that are contributing to the ailments
and the chronic lifestyle diseases.
But on top of that,
by increasing the diversity
of what that plant-predominant diet looks like,
you are enhancing health in no small part
due to the fact that you're feeding your microbiome
in a manner
in which has all of these extra downstream impacts
on health enhancement.
Yeah, let's perhaps zoom in on the microbiome
for a moment here.
And not to repeat what you've done with Dr. B,
but perhaps we can build on that.
The human body is made up of around 23,000 human genes.
There are around 100 times that many genes in our microbes.
So, we are genetically more microbe than we are human.
And I think there's been some revision on the maths
around how many human cells are there to microbe cells.
Right, yeah, there's been some changes.
There's been some changes and used to be 10 to one,
it was thought that it was 10 microbial cells
to one human cell.
And that's been revised to around 1.3 microbial cells
It's a big change.
It's a big change,
but it still speaks to the fact that
from a cell point of view,
we still have more microbial cells
than we do have human cells.
I mentioned before there are around 38 trillion microbes
in our gastrointestinal system.
That is more than the number of stars
that are in the Milky Way.
It's wild.
There is a whole lot going in there
that we have underappreciated for a long time
and these microbes, they rely on us and we rely on them.
It's a symbiotic relationship.
And you mentioned diversity
and the reason why diversity of plants
in the diet is important is that we have about 500
to 1000 different species within our gut of bacteria.
And a more diverse microbiome
is associated with better health.
We see healthy people have a more diverse microbiome.
Increasing the number of species of those microbes.
Yes, so, most people will have a sort of predefined number
of species between 500 to 1000
and that is usually defined
in the first three years of life.
And so increasing diversity
is really working with what you already have,
but it's increasing the prevalence of the healthy bacteria,
the numbers of them and suppressing
or reducing the numbers of the pathogenic bacteria.
I think perhaps a good analogy of this
is thinking about society.
When there's equal representation of people
from different cultures,
we have a better functioning society.
Each of these people from diverse backgrounds
are bringing different skills to the table.
And same thing in society,
there are of course a minority of people
who get up to no good and--
Pathogenic citizens.
The pathogenics and we wanna keep them at bay
and that's the same thing with the microbiome.
And so when you have better representation,
essentially if you think about a football team as well,
you could think about on any given day
if a couple of players aren't performing their best,
some of the other players can pick up the slack
and you can still win the game.
That's what it means,
when you have a more diverse microbiome, more robust,
you're more likely to be winning
in producing these compounds
that are protecting your gut lining.
And I'll go into that.
These different species essentially like you and I,
have different food preferences,
slightly different taste buds
and so the prebiotic fiber and the polyphenols
and the resistant starch in certain foods
will help promote the growth of certain species,
but then other foods will help promote the growth
of different species.
And so when you have a diverse range of plants in your diet,
you're keeping more of these guys happier.
And as you feed them, they're producing metabolites.
So, they ferment these food products
that pass through undigested into the large intestine
and as they're fermenting them,
they are producing these metabolites,
there are 1000s of these, but probably the most studied
and spoken about are short-chain fatty acids.
And of the short-chain fatty acids,
butyrate probably gets most of the attention
and it kinda rightly so.
Butyrate helps to keep the mucosal layer of the gut intact,
healthy, along with the endothelial cells
which sit right between it, just a very thin layer of cells
sit between all the microbes,
the 38 trillion microbes
and then 70% of your immune system.
Which is important because we're seeing this rise
in the incidence of conditions
like all sort of colitis, et cetera,
all of these gut digestion issues
which really relate to gut lining permeability.
Yeah, if you look at the surge
in autoimmune conditions and allergies,
they've increased far too rapidly
for that to be down to human genetics.
Human genetics take a lot longer than that to change.
We're talking hundreds of 1000s, millions of years usually.
So, something else has changed.
And when we look at the microbiome,
it's clear that people
who are experiencing these types of autoimmune conditions,
they tend to have dysbiosis.
Now, I think it would be far-fetched
to say that a causal relationship has been established
for some of these,
a lot of this is epidemiology and it's an association,
but there are mechanisms that do make sense.
And so the idea is that if you have dysbiosis
and you have less of these short-chain fatty acids
being produced--
And just to be clear,
dysbiosis being a dysregulation
of your gut health in general.
Yes, so you've lost that diversity
and you get a relative reduction in the healthful microbes
and you get an increase
in the pathogenic inflammatory microbes.
And when this happens,
you get breakdown of that mucosal layer,
you get separation of the endothelial cells,
so the endothelial cells are held together
by tight junctions and butyrate,
that short-chain fatty acid that I mentioned,
one of the functions that it has in the gut
is to help keep those tight junctions in good health.
And so as you get this more inflammatory state in the gut
and dysbiosis, you get breakdown of that layer.
This is important because it allows the flow of molecules
from the gut into the bloodstream
that shouldn't be getting through the gut lining.
And these are often referred to as bacterial endotoxins
and they essentially travel into the bloodstream
where they rev up the immune system.
And when you're driving up inflammation,
you're increasing oxidative stress for the body
and oxidative stress leads to DNA damage
and then you're like starting to accelerate
the aging process of tissues.
So, what are the foods that are most butyrate-promoting?
Great question.
Have you heard a professor Christopher Gardner?
I think so.
So, this brings us to a very interesting study
that just came out.
He's a professor at Stanford
and he was working with the Sonambergs.
The Sonamnbergs are arguably
some of the leading microbiome scientists in the world and--
Is it a a husband and a wife--
Yeah.
Yeah, I've heard of them.
And they just conducted a really eloquently designed study
that took 38 adults if my memory serves me correct
and randomized them into two groups.
And the idea was really to see
how fiber affects the microbiome
and how fermented foods do.
And of course fermented foods contain probiotics.
So, the hypothesis was that maybe they improve diversity
and the idea is to test and see if there's a difference
between fiber and fermented foods.
And this was a 10-week study.
The subjects that were told to increase fiber,
they increased their fiber from 20 grams to 40.
The subjects in the fermented food group,
they were told to eat six serves of fermented foods a day.
To give you an example, one combo jar was two serves.
There was sauerkraut, there was kefir,
there was some yogurt,
there was about five
or six different probiotic-rich, fermented foods
and the results of this study were really interesting
because there was some findings
that I guess challenged the idea
that fiber leads to increased diversity.
In the fermented food group, we'll start there,
they saw across the board, aggregate
increases in microbial diversity
and really impressive increases.
So, a real strong finding
and a good reason to add more fermented foods to your diet.
They also measured markers of inflammation
and they measured around 200 odds.
So, a very comprehensive look at inflammatory markers.
And they saw that the fermented foods
drove down inflammatory proteins, 19 of them specifically.
So, the introduction of fermented foods
was leading to a better immune response
and decreasing inflammation in the body.
Now, the fiber group, very interesting,
there was an individualized response.
So, if you look at the aggregate, just the average,
the fiber group did not see an increase
in microbiome diversity.
And that's an interesting finding
and you kind of have to dig into the study
to make sense of that--
Why would that be?
I mean, that up ends prior conclusions around that?
It does and when you dig into the study
and I've spoken with Dr. Gardner about this,
there were some individuals
who handled the increase in fiber really well
and they saw an increase in diversity.
And then there were some who didn't
and actually saw an increase in inflammation.
And they thought this was really interesting
because this finding
is kind of in spite of previous understanding.
And what they found was when they went back
and looked at baseline diversity,
the people who didn't respond so great
to increasing fiber,
they essentially had very poor diversity to begin with.
And so there are a couple of hypotheses from this study,
it's not to write off fiber at all.
It's just to say that maybe in certain circumstances,
jacking your fiber up from 20 grams to 40 grams overnight
is not ideal for some people
and perhaps they need tools and strategies
to increase their diversity first
before they're increasing.
And so one of the hypotheses is that
if your microbiome is really struggling
and you don't have diversity,
perhaps you have a long history
of using antibiotics for example
and you've been eating a lot of ultra-processed foods
and living a very high-stress life...
The stress affects the microbiome as well,
then perhaps it could be a better strategy
to introduce fermented foods first, increase some diversity
and then start to add more plant diversity
and more fiber into the diet
when your gut is in a better position
to be able to handle it.
How long was the study conducted for?
So, this was a 10-week study.
It would be interesting to see how that would play out
over six months
perhaps if you just continue to eat fiber at some point,
your microbiome locks in on that,
but that idea of fermented foods
kind of turbocharging things
and getting you prepared
to be in a position to take advantage of additional fiber
in your diet I think is super interesting.
Yeah, so I think they gonna go and test that
and they may even look at a probiotic supplement I believe
as well, but the other thing to consider here
and your point is a great one
because duration of this study is important.
And that was one thing they commented on.
Perhaps over longer exposure,
the microbiome would have adapted
and being better able to handle that increase in fiber
and then you would see proliferation of the bacteria,
but the other thing I think that's important here is that
it was an overnight jump from 20 to 40 grams.
Would it have been different
if it was a very slow progression?
So, look, some of that remains to be seen,
but that's the beautiful thing about science.
It's constantly evolving.
We know that from the gut microbiome project,
which is led by a microbiome researcher, Rob Knight,
he has this huge project and has been creating this database
where people send in their stool samples
and also send in information about what they eat
and he's been able to create a really cool library.
And we know from that,
that compared to people who are eating ten
or fewer plants per week,
those that are eating 30 or more have much more diversity
in their microbiome, so--
That's Dr. B's whole thing.
Like if you're gonna do one thing,
increase the diversity of plants on your plate.
Yes, so I think that recommendation still stands.
I guess the only thing that I would add there is that
the process to increasing that diversity
it might look a little different
depending on what someone's baseline diversity looks like.
Sure and the clickbait title version of that
would be forget about fiber, it's all about fermented foods.
A simplified--
And that happened.
So, that happened and Hannah...
I can't remember Hannah's surname,
but this study was part of her PhD.
And I've heard her speak
and she kind of had a bit of a laugh about that
because that's not what the study shows,
it is a lot more nuanced than that.
As the world tends to be.
That's fascinating.
Is there a way...
I wanna switch gears in a minute,
but to kind of put a pin in this,
what's the best way for somebody to figure out
what the diversity of their microbiome looks like,
are there tests?
Can you like get a stool sample or something like that?
How does that work?
There are a couple of different companies
that are doing this, I'm not sure how reliable they are yet,
I'm told that they're getting more and more reliable
so actually this a great question
because I think this could be a capha
in helping people work out what steps they should take.
But in the meantime,
a good rule of thumb is increase both your fiber
and your fermented foods?
Yep and you may need to experiment a little bit with that
to work with your body and listen to your body,
but I think certainly the key finding
from that study is that fermented foods are beneficial.
And all of us should be eating more kimchi and sauerkraut
and if you eat animal products and you eat dairy,
then I would argue that fermented dairy is probably the best
of the dairy options.
And I do think that some of that technology
that you just spoke to, it will become better over time,
I think Zoey is one that's out there.
I'm not sure whether they report so much on diversity
in terms of a diversity score for the person,
but they do take a stool sample
and they do recommend foods.
And that's being led by Tim Spector
who is certainly a sort of prominent expert in this space.
Zoe.
I suppose it's called Zoe.
Yeah.
Final question on this point,
what is your sense
of the efficacy of store-bought kombucha products?
You see them advertised with a certain number attached
to what that culture looks like,
but then I think,
"Well, these things are pasteurized on some level,"
like I could make kombucha at home and we've done that,
I'm sure the ones we make at home
are gonna be more efficacious
than what I'm buying at the store,
but I've often just thought like,
this is probably not doing anything,
it's more of a placebo type situation,
but I don't know if you look at that
or are there studies on this?
I'm with you, I don't think there are studies on that,
but I choose the raw, non-pasteurized kombucha,
you can find a few of those.
There are some here that are found in California
for that reason,
I think if you're pasteurizing them and heating them,
then you are--
Defeats the whole entire purpose of the whole thing.
Yeah, those microbes are likely being killed.
Now, in saying that, to add a layer of complexity to this,
there is a lot of research now looking at dead microbes
and these are often called post biotics.
And there are some studies showing benefit
even through the consumption of dead probiotics.
So, that's interesting,
I don't think we fully understand is pasteurized kombucha
and perhaps the dead cultures that are in there
is that exerting benefit within our gut and downstream?
So, I think my advice would be to either try
and make your own or to look for one that is a raw,
non-pasteurized kombucha.
Get your scoby going at home.
Switching gears, I wanna talk about saturated fat.
When you articulated your thesis
at the beginning of the show,
a big piece in that was the reduction of saturated fat
and when we talk about saturated fat, this is a hot button,
hotly debated thing particularly on social media
depending upon your particular dietary tribe of choice.
The overwhelming evidence from my perspective
of valid, objective science is pretty clear
that saturated fat, no bueno, contributing to heart disease
and other not so good health outcomes.
So, walk us through your sense of the science
with respect to dietary saturated fat intake,
the impact that it has and why we should be reducing it.
How far back should we go?
I don't know.
We go as long as you want.
There's a great study from 1908.
That still holds up?
Yeah, well, it's interesting
because pre-1908, atherosclerosis...
A lot of what we're talking about
when we're talking about saturated fat is its effect
on LDL cholesterol
and then the effect that that has
on the accumulation of fat in your artery,
the development of plaque,
in science it's called atherosclerosis,
which then puts you at higher risk
of having heart attack or stroke.
And prior to 1908 however,
the prevailing sort of idea around cardiovascular disease
was that it was just a process of aging
and it wasn't necessarily driven through a dietary exposure.
And this early research goes back to Russia.
These Russian scientists were in the lab,
the first one's really doing work in this space
and there was a researcher, last name Ignatowski
and he fed meat and dairy products to a rabbit
and was able to see that that rabbit developed fatty streaks
in its arteries.
And that was really the very first study
that was like,
"Hang on, maybe the development of fatty streaks,
atherosclerosis that we're seeing in humans
is not just aging."
However, from that study,
the hypothesis was that it was animal protein.
And about four or five years later, 1913, Nikolai Anichkov,
quite a famous name in the sort of science world
for cardiovascular disease, another Russian,
he was looking at the fatty streaks in arteries
and could see that there was a lot of cholesterol in there
and so he had a hypothesis that maybe in that 1908 study,
maybe it was cholesterol that was in those foods
and it wasn't protein
that was causing this arterial plaque to form.
So, he ran a study again with a rabbit
and one group were fed a sunflower seed oil
and one were fed sunflower seed oil with cholesterol in it.
And he was able to see that quite clearly,
the rabbits that were fed the sunflower oil
with cholesterol dissolved into it
developed the fatty streaks
and the sort of the pathology
that goes on to become atherosclerosis.
Now, that research then was really groundbreaking.
But what happened was immediately after that,
some other researches
and he decided to look at replicating that study in rats
and in dogs.
So, again feeding dietary cholesterol to these animals
and looking to see if there was any buildup of this fat
in the arteries.
And what they found was there wasn't.
And so they thought this was a bit of an anomaly,
maybe it's just something that happens in a rabbit,
which is a herbivore
and there was no further science done for quite some time.
Now, the key thing that was overlooked there was that
in the rabbit model, the rabbit was fed something,
it increased the LDL cholesterol in that rabbit,
which then had led to the buildup of the fatty streak.
The rat and the dog, the models,
the reason there was no fatty buildup in the artery
was because they metabolize cholesterol differently
and so the consumption of dietary cholesterol
didn't increase their cholesterol levels in their blood.
And so having sort of overlooked that
and also the fact that all of this was published in Russian,
it was kind of parked by the Russians there
and wasn't seen by the rest of the world
and then 20 or 30 years later
is when some American researchers, Kin Sell and keys,
they were looking at metabolic ward studies
where they're bringing people in
and they wanted to see if they could identify
what components of the diet
would increase cholesterol levels in the blood
because the idea at that point in time was that
high serum cholesterol was driving heart disease.
And you've got to remember cardiovascular disease peaked
in the 1950s.
There was essentially a national inquiry
following the president of America, president Roosevelt,
he died of heart disease in 1944.
And so these guys were running these metabolic ward studies
and they were able to very clearly show in humans,
when you feed someone saturated fat,
you increase the levels of LDL cholesterol in their blood.
On the other hand,
when you feed someone polyunsaturated fats,
you will drive down their cholesterol.
In fact in their calculation,
what they were able to deduce was that
saturated fat will increase cholesterol
at a rate of around twice as much as polyunsaturated fat
will lower it.
They were also able to tease out
that dietary cholesterol in humans,
while it doesn't have as significant effect
as saturated fat, it still does affect cholesterol levels.
And they came up with a calculation
that still stands to this day.
It still stands to this day.
The more saturated fats in the diet
and the less polyunsaturated fats,
the higher someone's LDL cholesterol levels are.
And the incidence of atherosclerosis.
Yes, so what we know is that
the higher your LDL cholesterol
and the longer you're exposed to that over a lifetime,
the higher your risk is to develop atherosclerosis.
And there is an interesting study out of Spain
called the PISA study
and this study essentially took 4,000 healthy adults
and they used ultrasound to look at the plaque
in their arteries.
And these were healthy adults
without cardiovascular disease.
And the recommendations in this country
and around the world are LDL cholesterol
should be around 100 milligrams per deciliter.
And so they ultrasounded all of these different participants
who had varying LDL cholesterol levels.
And what they found was that
even at that 100 milligrams per deciliter level,
which we consider to be normal,
but we consider it to be normal
in quite an unhealthy population.
What they found was that at that level,
40% of people had atherosclerosis.
And it wasn't until you got down
to around 50, 60, 70 milligrams per deciliter,
did you see people without atherosclerosis.
So, a couple observations.
First, wasn't there a study done on young soldiers
who had died in World War I where they autopsy them
and they realized perhaps for the first time
that young people had these fatty streaks
in their cardiovascular system?
It was the Korean War I believe.
Oh, Korean War--
And around 70% of the American soldiers
that were killed from gunfire--
These are like 18 to 24 or whatever.
Around 70% of them had atherosclerosis.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome,
but I wanna snack a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants, more fruits,
vegetable, seeds, beans and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the plantpower meal planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to 1000s
of highly customizable, super delicious
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com
and right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off in annual membership.
Let's get back to the show.
And then the second thing that I want to bring up,
you mentioned Ancel Keys.
I mean, this is a guy who is legendary
for his breakthrough science,
but also somebody who has a scarlet letter attached to him,
there's a whole narrative around this guy being a quack
and why we shouldn't pay any attention
to anything that he discovered
and this narrative is being propagated
by a different dietary drive like the sort of carnivore
and low-carb community of people.
So, walk us through truth and fiction
when it comes to Ancel Keys,
where he sits in the canon of legitimate, verifiable science
that's trustworthy versus this idea
that he should be dismissed for reasons X, Y and Z.
If you take a position that carbohydrates are to blame
for all disease and you blame the 1980 guidelines,
which are quite notorious,
everyone refers to them as the guidelines that came out
and told people to eat low fat and look what happened,
population got sicker and sicker.
If you take the position that--
Never mind that people didn't follow those guidelines,
but anyway--
And we should get into that, that's really important.
If you take that position, then you need a scapegoat.
You need someone to blame who's responsible for this.
And unfortunately, Ancel Keys is that guy
for a lot of people and they blame him
for the development of the low-fat guidelines
that came out in 1980.
Now, if you go back and look at Key's work,
I would say arguably he has made the greatest contribution
to nutrition science in the last 100 years.
This relationship between saturated fat and cholesterol
and atherosclerosis is the most solid relationship
that exists today.
If that's wrong,
then we need to throw out all of nutrition science.
And people think that he just performed
this Seven Countries Study.
But as I just mentioned then,
he started before that in the metabolic wards.
He started in metabolic ward trials,
very controlled settings, bringing people in,
feeding them different fats, exposing them to animal fats,
to vegetable oils
and looking what happens to their cholesterol.
From there, he was able to create a hypothesis.
He could see that the saturated fats, the animal fats
were driving up cholesterol.
Now he wanted to go out in the real world
and look at populations that exist
and compare those populations eating lots of animal fats
with high cholesterol,
what's their cardiovascular disease incidents like
compared to other populations eating less animal fats
with lower cholesterol?
And prior to the Seven Countries Study
is what he's most known for.
And prior to that, he did a speech at a conference
and on a chart, he put up the saturated fat intake
and level of cardiovascular disease from six countries.
And people today look at that and say,
"Well, he cherry-picked those six countries,
there was actually 22."
Now, in Keys' defense, he chose those six countries
because that's where the best data was.
He wasn't happy with the data from the other countries.
You remember this is back in the 1950s.
So, some of the population data wasn't that great.
Now, the main point here is that some folks at that time
who were arguing with Ancel Keys said that in actual fact
there's 22 countries.
And they produced a graph which is very famous now,
you'll see the six versus the 22.
And the 22 didn't actually refute
what Ancel Keys was saying.
It just made the association a little weaker, now--
And the reason that he did not focus
on those other countries was that the data was error-ridden
or incomplete because of reporting inconsistencies
or just issues related to creating verifiable data sets.
Yeah, how verifiable it is,
there are problems with diagnosis for example in countries
and how they were categorizing the deaths
for certain people.
But I think what's really important is that
when he went to set up the Seven Countries Study,
he invited many, many countries and this is overlooked.
He's written about this.
He wanted to work with established nutrition scientists
in these countries
and essentially, he even invited France
which often gets brought up and they declined.
So, he was working with those that accepted the invitation
and had established nutrition science centers
who could conduct the research with him,
it was a collaboration.
And so there were seven countries chosen
and within that there were 16 cohorts.
These countries were the USA, there was Finland,
there was Greece, there was Yugoslavia,
which today has been separated, there was Japan
and there was the Netherlands, that's the seven countries
and then within those,
some of those countries had multiple cohorts,
there ended up being 16 different cohorts.
And the really nice thing about this study was that
there was great differences in the amount of saturated fat
between these cohorts.
You need that contrast.
If you're just looking at lots of populations
and their saturated fat consumption is very similar,
then you're not providing enough contrast
to see whether high versus low saturated fat consumption
is affecting heart disease.
So, he conducted this research
and it was able to establish relatively quickly
that countries like Greece and Japan
who had low saturated fat intake,
around 6 to 8% of calories
had significantly lower incidence of heart disease
compared to countries like the Netherlands
and the USA and Finland who had saturated fat intakes
around 16 to 20% of calories.
Wow, so what we glean from that is a pretty clear picture
of the relationship between saturated fat intake
and heart disease incidents that holds up to this day
and the research around this relationship has only continued
to kind of build on that premise.
Yeah, like that was just the start.
There's been extensive research since then.
And I should add that another criticism
that Keys often gets is that he was not paying attention
to refined carbohydrates.
And that's not true.
His own study show that there is a relationship
between refined carbohydrates and cardiovascular disease,
but that association is weaker.
It is weaker than saturated fat and cardiovascular disease.
And in fact in 1968
when Keys was providing recommendations
for Scandinavian dietary guidelines,
limiting refined sugars was one of his recommendations.
And he wasn't just this guy that was obsessed
just with saturated fat.
That was very much the start of his work
and over the course of his work,
he's most well known for being an advocate
of the Mediterranean dietary pattern.
And he's the one that went on
to describe that dietary pattern as I referred to earlier
as sort of largely vegetarian diet
with modest amounts of fish and dairy.
So, when we see the carnivore diet proponents out there,
the Paul Saladinos and the Shawn Bakers
advocating for this notion
that everything you ever thought you knew
about saturated fat is wrong, saturated fat is your friend,
what are they hanging their hat on
in terms of establishing that this is not harmful?
Compared to what Rich?
I don't know, you tell me.
That's the million-dollar question here.
There are a bunch of meta analyses
that seem to make saturated fat look okay.
And you can do that depending on what you compare it to.
And I said before there's been mountains of evidence
that have come out since the Seven Countries Study
and part of that has been teasing out exactly this.
If you swap calories from saturated fat
for calories in refined carbohydrates,
then that's a lateral move.
It could even increase risk of cardiovascular disease.
Yeah and you're kind of alluding to...
There was a study that garnered a lot of press
that said saturated fat isn't related to heart disease--
The PURE study.
It was really...
Yeah, exactly.
But what it really said was
maybe it's not quite as bad as we originally thought,
but it's still bad.
How do you interpret that?
The way I interpret the PURE study in particular
is that...
This was a multi-country study
and there are always some limitations
when you're comparing different socio-economic classes
and in that study,
the people that were eating less saturated fat
were tending to eat diets below the poverty line.
And they were diets
that contained a lot of refined carbohydrates,
very little diversity and sure, in a diet like that,
the addition of some animal fats
may improve their health.
I wouldn't argue against that.
But consistently if you look at what happens
if you swap calories from saturated fat
for polyunsaturated fats like vegetable oils
or nuts and seeds or even fatty fish
or for monounsaturated fats or for whole grains,
you see that you drive down heart disease risk.
So, I think the key takeaway point here is
you can make saturated fat look good,
it depends what you're comparing it with
and whether removing saturated fat from your diet
is healthy or not depends what you're replacing it with.
If you are replacing it with nuts, seeds, fatty fish
if you eat seafood or whole grains,
then you are going to be lowering your risk
of heart disease.
Another talking point that gets thrown around
from those communities,
I feel like they've pivoted a little bit away
from the saturated fat thing
and now it's all about vilifying seed oils.
Like that's become like the evil culprit in this whole thing
in a very reductionist way.
So, walk me through that argument
and kind of where things stand
in terms of not just seed oils,
but also the whole conversation
around the health implications of oil in the diet,
whether we're talking about Esselstyn's super no to low oil,
plant-based diet
to people who are very kind of pro-olive oil and all that.
I mean, that's a large, big question--
Maybe we start
with the sort of omega-6-rich vegetable oil, seed oils
and then we'll go into olive oil and the vegan diet,
the low-fat vegan diet.
That rhetoric around omega-6 oils being to blame,
seed oils being to blame for disease,
it's something I've studied super closely
because it really intrigues me
because I find it incredibly hard
to see how someone can take that position
from an evidence-based point of view.
But I think this is a prime example where emotions
and facts don't mix very well.
And when you're really affected by emotions,
it can affect objectivity.
And so I said before the 1980 guidelines came out
and a lot of people will say that those guidelines
pushed people off of animal fats
and pushed them towards seed oils and vegetable oils.
Right, being a primary ingredient
in ultra-processed foods.
Sure and I would be the first person to put my hand up
and say that seed oils within ultra-processed foods,
I don't think anyone should be eating
more ultra-processed foods.
But we need to remember there is much more
than just seed oils in those ultra-processed foods,
there's added sugar and there's added salt
and a whole lot of other additives.
Refined grains too.
That's right.
So, where does this idea that omega-6s seed oils
are inflammatory or causing disease come from?
Let's go back to the evidence hierarchy.
So, I think firstly from an anecdotal point of view,
a lot of people who believe that saito is a bad,
they've removed ultra-processed foods from their diet
and they feel better.
So, I understand that, that's a lived experience,
but I think they're wrongly attributing that benefit
to the reduction of seed oils
when in fact it's just the removal of ultra-processed foods
from their diet.
If you look at the strongest kind of arguments
for omega-6s being inflammatory,
all of this is in vitro animal study science.
And as we mentioned earlier,
not everything that happens at that level
plays out in humans.
And we know from significant amounts
of randomized controlled trials,
randomized controlled trials,
if people substitute saturated fat for vegetable oils
or seed oils, they reduce their risk of heart disease.
That's the first thing.
The second is that omega-6s when you consume them,
the body desaturates and elongates them
into a biologically active form,
a bit like what happens to omega-3s,
people have probably heard that plant-based omega-3s
go through a similar pathway
where they are converted to DHA and EPA.
Same thing happens with omega-6s.
And along this pathway when you consume omega-6s
which is linoleic acid,
this is a fat that is quite concentrated in seed oils,
along that pathway,
a fat called arachidonic acid is produced.
And the idea from a mechanism point of view is that
this is a precursor to inflammatory compounds.
But when we look at human intervention studies,
if you feed people seed oils,
you don't get an increase in arachidonic acid,
you don't see it.
Secondly, if you feed people omega-6 linoleic acid,
you do not get an increase in inflammatory biomarkers.
That's probably the most important thing
for us to think about here.
It just doesn't happen.
Despite the putative mechanism
and what you see in in vitro or animal studies,
it doesn't play out in human studies.
And then if you zoom right out
and you look at large population studies
and you look at people consuming more linoleic acid
or who have higher amounts of linoleic acid
in their tissues,
they have lower risk of cardiovascular disease
and lower risk of total mortality.
But would that not be to play devil's advocate,
another example of compared to what?
Is not the conventional wisdom still?
Like what I've heard for years is
most people are consuming way too much omega-6
and it's all about the ratio
or proportion of omega-6 intake to Omega-3
and we're being told to increase our omega-3s
and reduce our omega-6
to bring that into kind of proper relationship.
Is that still the scientific sort of perspective
or is this new studies that have changed that?
I don't think that is the position today.
I think that there is overwhelming evidence
to show that that ratio where I do think it is important
is that the omega-6 pathway
and the omega-3 pathway share enzymes.
And so there is a possibility
if you have a lot of omega-6s in your diet,
then you're using up all those enzymes
and you may struggle to convert the Omega-3s from ALA
to DHA and EPA.
So, I don't think that's been fully borne out in the science
other than to say I think there is some evidence
particularly people with chronic inflammation
like rheumatoid arthritis
that does seem to be a benefit for them to lower omega-6s
in their diet.
But overall, if you look at human health outcome data
when you're feeding healthy adults omega-6s
in quite large volumes, you're not dialing up inflammation
and when we look at a population level,
people that are consuming a lot of these omega-6s
as I said they do have lower risk of cardiovascular disease,
lower risk of premature death.
Is that provided those omega-6s are not pre-packaged
in an ultra-processed food
where there's all these other factors to consider?
Yeah, I think so.
And that's kind of where I land on this.
I mean, firstly, I'm not sort of pro-seed
or pro-vegetable oils, you don't have to weigh them--
Let's make that clear because it does sound like,
"Hey, like no problem with omega-6s,
knock yourself out with seed oil."
What I'm saying is I just don't think they're the poison
that they're made out to be.
I certainly don't think
that we should be increasing our exposure
to ultra-processed foods,
but I don't think we need to generate the fear
over vegetable oils
and certainly don't need to blame the increased burden
of chronic disease since 1980.
That's not from people swapping butter with a vegetable oil
in their cooking.
It's a lot more complex than that,
since 1980 the consumption of these ultra-processed foods
has increased hugely
and as I said, I'm not a huge sort of pro-seed oil person
and particularly someone's watching their weight,
I think all oils are very calorie-dense
and we need to be mindful of that,
they're bringing about 120 calories per tablespoon,
so they're quite easy to over consume.
You mentioned olive oil and the vegan diet.
Yeah, I mean, within the plant-based vegan world,
there are sub communities within that
that are at odds with each other
over the health implications
of including something like olive oil in the diet.
On the one hand, you have Caldwell Esselstyn and his camp
that is very anti-oil.
That's a contingent of people
who are primarily focused on preventing
and reversing heart disease
and Caldwell is somebody who's treating people
for the most part who are very ill
and he's very adamant in that perspective
and has done his studies and written books about this
and then on the other end,
you have a different contingent of people
that include like Danielle Bilardo and some other folks
who are saying the science doesn't bear out
the negative health implications of olive oil
on a plant-based diet, we vilified this.
There is space and room within a healthy plant-based diet
to include this, what say you sir?
So, I guess firstly, the likes of Dean Ornish
and Dr. Esselstyn, these guys are giants--
Yes, legends.
And they have done so much good for health
across the globe, reached millions and millions of people
and their diets work.
I am of the view that there is no definitive evidence
that the addition of olive oil for example
to a plant-based diet makes it inferior
and perhaps it could make it superior in some ways
and I think if you look at say Dean Ornish's study
for example, I think people look at that and say...
Or even Esselstyn's study,
that there was no oil in those studies
and therefore that must be why they got the results
that they did.
But in the case of Dean Ornish,
you have to realize that compared to the control group,
there was many changes, it wasn't just--
There were a lot of lifestyle changes that they made
that were part of that
and he's never tried to say otherwise.
Exactly and I mean just from a dietary point of view,
there were many changes though.
People increasing their fruit and vegetable consumption
and decreasing their animal product consumption
and the removal of oil was just one change of many.
So, you would really need a third arm in that study
to try and independently tease out the effects of oil.
And in fact,
you would need to change the study design a little bit
to remove the exercise and the stress component
and all these other variables
that could be affecting the outcome.
So, I think that there's a little bit
of kind of overextrapolation from that study
and also Essylstn's study as well that's an oil-free diet.
There are some nuances with that study
that are still debated,
but I don't think we need to sort of go into that.
If you then zoom out
and look at other studies like PREDIMED
and PREDIMED was a study of around 7,000 people,
primary prevention, so they didn't have heart disease
and they had a control group, standard care, standard diet,
they had two intervention groups.
These were Mediterranean diets, one with oil
and one with nuts, olive oil I should say.
And they saw over a five-year period,
those in the Mediterranean groups had around 30% reduction
in cardiovascular disease events
and there was no difference between the Mediterranean group
that had nuts added
or the Mediterranean group that had olive oil added.
So, that kind of speaks to the fact that
olive oil can be included in a healthy diet.
It's not to say that there's not going to be a future study
that does look at the independent effects of olive oil
in a completely plant-based diet and shows a difference,
but at this stage,
I think it's kind of the least of most people's concerns,
the most important things are driving saturated fat down.
We know that the inclusion of polyunsaturated fats
as I spoke to earlier from those metabolic ward studies
is actually very important.
These polyunsaturated fats are inherently beneficial,
they will help to lower cholesterol.
So, their inclusion through nuts and seeds or olive oil
if that's right for you I think is a good idea.
So, when someone hits you up and says,
"Simon, I hear everything you're saying,
you make a lot of sense, but I've been on a low-carb diet
or I've been on a keto diet and I'm having great results.
I feel great I've lost a bunch of weight,"
what is your response to that?
Like how do you think about low-carb diets,
the keto diet, et cetera in contrast to a higher-carb,
plant-based diet?
I might just add one thing to the oil.
Well, hold that thought because I just remembered something
that I think is important.
There are some studies
showing that oil impairs endothelial cell function
and you may have heard that before.
And these are acute studies
looking at when you feed someone oil,
what happens in the postprandial period
after they consume that oil
to their endothelial cell function?
And you see that it is impaired.
And that is often science that people point to to say,
"Hey, look."
Impaired of what, what does that mean?
Well, you get a change in blood flow,
a negative change in blood flow.
And so the idea here is that the consumption of oil
is negatively affecting the endothelial cell function,
endothelial cells line the arteries
and if this is happening acutely,
maybe it explains what's happening chronically.
But there is I guess some issues with this train of thought
exercise also acutely impairs endothelial cell function
and so does sleep.
So, it's interesting,
but I guess we have to consider
that not everything that happens acutely
is representative of what happens chronically.
And sometimes an acute stress
can actually lead to an adaptation and a benefit
in the long-term.
So, I think that's worthwhile adding.
So, onto the next thing that I asked you about.
Low carb versus high carb?
Basically.
From a weight loss point of view,
there is a plethora of studies
that have essentially shown
there is no significant benefit to either.
And some of probably the best design studies
come from professor Christopher Gardner
out of Stanford.
He initially ran a study in the early 2000s
called the A to Z study and this featured Atkins,
it featured the Zone diet, the Learn diet
and the Ornish diet.
All of these have a different ratio of macronutrients,
so some of them are low-carb, some are high-carb
and 12-months trial.
By the end of that 12 months,
there was no significant difference
between Atkins and Ornish and Atkins is the lowest-carb
and Ornish is the highest-carb.
Strictly through the rubric of weight loss.
This is strictly through the rubric of weight loss
and the idea with this was they had dieticians
who would use the most prominent books, so the Atkins book
and the Ornish book at the time
to educate people on how to adopt these diets.
And that's what--
So, this was done a while ago then?
Those books like the "Zone Diet"
was like in the early 90s, right?
Yes, so this was done I think in 2003.
And there was a very interesting finding though Rich
from this study.
And that was that within the groups, so within the low-carb
and within the high-carb, some people did really well
and some people did really poorly.
So, there was this sort of wide variation.
And Christopher Gardner was left thinking,
"Well, I wonder what explains that?
Why would some people do really well on low-carb,
some do really poorly and the same for high-carb?"
And he thought maybe it's genetics
or perhaps it's insulin resistance,
how well your body can utilize glucose, carbohydrates.
And so he went away and got funding and ran another study,
a larger study, 600 people, again 12 months
called DIETFITS.
And this study only had two arms.
The two arms were a low-carb diet and a high-carb diet.
And he knew that what he would see in each group
was some people do really well and some really poorly
and he wanted to see if perhaps these genetic markers...
He was looking at three different genetic variations,
he wanted to see if they would affect the outcome
or if insulin resistance would affect the outcome.
And very interestingly,
none of that predicted who was successful
and who was unsuccessful in weight loss.
So, we're left in this position today
where that is largely unanswered.
For some reason some people do better on high-carb
and there's certain people that are doing better
on low-carb.
And perhaps future research will tease out why that is,
but at this stage,
I've kind of changed my view a little bit I'd have to say
on low-carb and I think I've softened my approach a bit.
If that works for someone,
then I think that meeting them where they are
is the better approach
and that's not to say you can't do a low-carb diet
in a healthy way.
I mean, it's what kind of low-carb diet,
if you're doing a low-carb diet
that's rife with saturated fat
and all these other things that we've been talking about,
not so good,
but there are ways of doing it in a healthy manner.
Yeah, so you can...
Going back to that theme, the plant-predominant theme,
you can do a low-carb diet within that theme.
And instead of loading up on the red meats and the dairy,
you're going to be more emphasizing the nuts and the seeds
and the plant protein.
And since writing this book
and I'm not sure exactly what communities have been speaking
about the book,
but I've had a number of people from the low-carb community
get in contact with me.
And what I've realized Rich is there are a lot of people
in the low-carb community who despite what Paul Saladino
and Shawn Baker might be saying about cholesterol,
there are a lot of people who do believe the science,
low-carb's working for them, they're losing weight,
but they do believe the science
when it comes to heart disease and they are fearful.
These are young parents, people 40s and 50s
who they found a way of eating
that does help them lose weight,
but at the same time they go to their doctor
and their doctor's like, "What are you doing?
We need to put you on a statin."
And that's scary.
So, what I found is that there are a large number of people
who are really receptive to this idea of,
"Hang on, you don't have to abandon this approach
that's working for you.
You can actually do it in a way that is evidence-based,
we can keep you on this path of weight loss
if that's right for you and at the same time,
we can modify the foods that are in that diet
in a way that will drive your cholesterol levels down,
drive your insulin resistance down
and overall not just deliver on weight loss,
but also put you at lower risk of these diseases."
And what would some of those cornerstone foods be?
So, it's all about driving the saturated fat down
and increasing polyunsaturated fats.
You're trying to cut back on meats and dairy in particular
and you're wanting to increase nuts and seeds
and seafood if you eat seafood
is a much better source of polyunsaturated fats,
much lower in saturated fats compared to meat.
So, those are the main little tweaks,
but also finding ways within their diet
to increase fiber as well is important
and you can do that in a low-carb manner
where instead of it being leaning heavily
on the sort of starchy foods,
you're really trying to increase the volume
of sort of low calorie, very nutrient-dense vegetables.
Like super low glycemic vegetables.
Yes, so lots of cruciferous vegetables
and dark, leafy greens.
And so you can easily shift this sort of animal-heavy,
low-carb diet to a more Mediterranean style, low-carb diet
and you see very quick, huge improvements
in their blood lipids, improvements in blood pressure
and they feel better.
But you personally eat around 50, 30, 20, right?
50% carb, 30% protein, 20% fat.
Yeah, if I was to count it out--
That's a lot of protein.
I think actually somewhere around there,
maybe or perhaps a little more fat
and a little less protein than that,
but that would be kind of around the mark
and that's what leaves me feeling the best.
I'm big on diet quality being more important
than focusing too much on the macronutrients,
the macronutrients can be important
if you have a very specific goal for example athletes
or bodybuilders, et cetera,
but I think what's more important first
is the quality of those macronutrients,
the quality of the fat, the quality of the carbohydrates,
it's less jelly beans, more black beans,
the quality of the protein--
That's my favorite quote
of yours by the way.
So, there are a lot of people
that are very anti-carbohydrates,
but carbohydrates is an umbrella term.
And what matters is
where you're getting those carbohydrates from.
If they're coming from jelly beans
then you're going to run into problems.
This idea in terms of
kind of falsified narratives out there
vilifying all carbohydrates,
lumping in the black beans
with the jelly beans is preposterous
or analogizing fruit to diet soda or soda, sugar soda.
We've talked extensively on this podcast about protein,
meeting your protein needs on a plant-based diet.
So, I don't wanna belabor the point,
but I haven't had you here to do it
and you being a very strong physical specimen,
I think it's worthy if somebody is tuning into this
and isn't familiar with either of us
and perhaps this is their first introduction
to some of the ideas we're talking about
to at least spend a couple of minutes
talking about the big protein question
because it still propagates
in terms of people who are interested
in moving towards a more plant-centric diet,
but are fearful of what that implies
in terms of meeting their protein needs
especially for the active people amongst that cohort.
So, this was a very large fear of mine
when I was initially making the changes to my diet.
And I always remind myself of that
because it's easy to kind of dismiss it
and forget that the sort of general school of thought
is that you get your protein from animal foods
and that plants are missing protein.
To this day, when you go to a restaurant
or you go to Chipotle, they say,
"What protein do you want on this?"
And very rarely does that include plant protein.
Although it's starting to change,
I think the food environment is starting to modify
and we're seeing increases in plant protein options
and I was chatting with Paul Shapiro
couple weeks ago now
and he's doing exciting things with microbe proteins--
It's pretty wild
what his company is doing right now with mushrooms.
Yeah, it's crazy,
feeding these fungi microbes potato and sorghum
and then producing this super protein-rich food,
I tried some as well and it's incredible, so--
Me I haven't tried it yet.
That's certainly the future of food.
But overall, I think there are a few aspects of protein
that are somewhat misunderstood
and we can perhaps clear up some of that confusion.
The first would be that plant protein
is missing certain essential amino acids.
And protein is made up of amino acids,
they are the little building blocks
and our body can make 11 of them
and the other nine are considered essential amino acids,
we have to get them through our food.
And the idea for many decades
has been that plants are missing some of those amino acids.
And you hear this idea of complete protein
and often people speak to quinoa and soy
and I think definition here is really important.
It's critical to this
because I think there's a misunderstanding
of what complete protein means.
I think most people think,
"Well, if quinoa and soy are complete proteins,
that means that these other plants are missing amino acids."
They're inferior.
Yeah or that they're just totally missing something.
And that's not true.
So, all plants contain all nine essential amino acids.
They're not missing,
they're just some of those plants
where certain amino acids are in lower amounts.
And so the definition of incomplete
actually by definition within science
although it's not used this way in general conversation
is not that an amino acid is missing,
it's just that it is in a smaller percentage
and if you were to eat only that food
for all of your calories,
then you might run into some trouble.
You might not consume enough of a certain amino acid
to meet your body's daily requirement.
So, you can imagine that that's kind of a useful definition
for developing countries,
places where there is food security problems
and if someone's living on one or two foods,
then that's important,
but if you're eating a diet
where you have an abundance of food options,
then really it's not that helpful.
And so if you are eating with diversity,
you might be consuming for example grains
that are low in lysine.
And look, it's true if you were to eat certain grains
and that was providing your 3,000,
two and a half thousand calories,
then you might fall short on lysine.
And the same could be said about certain beans.
If you eat a certain bean for all of your calories,
you might fall short on the thynine,
but beans are very rich in lysine
and when you start adding all these foods into your diet,
some might be low in certain amino acid,
but the other food is really high.
It's really an academic exercise
because almost no one is only eating one food
unless you're like the spud fit guy
who is eating just potatoes for a year
or you are in a developing country
and there's a legitimate food scarcity issue,
but almost everybody is eating at least two, three, five,
six, seven, 10 different foods
throughout the course of a day or two.
And if you're doing that,
you're eating with that diversity
and you're eating enough calories,
you will not run into problems.
You will get all of the essential amino acids
that your body needs.
And anyone can run a simple exercise, don't believe me,
download the chronometer app, it's a free app,
plug in a day of eating
and you will quickly see that you will exceed
the 100% recommended amount
for all nine essential amino acids.
And you'll see it's very hard not to exceed,
it would be more challenging to fall short on them
than it would be to consume enough of them.
Is there any validity to the argument of high quality
versus low quality proteins?
If we're meeting all of our essential amino acid needs,
is there a difference in plant protein X
versus animal protein Y
beyond just the narrow lens of amino acid intake?
I mean like IGF-1 and all these other things
that come into play in terms of the impact on our ability
to build and repair our muscles.
So, let's step back one step here.
I think it's important to acknowledge
that if you look at populations who are vegetarian
or are vegan across the board,
whether you're looking at populations in North America
or in Europe,
people are consuming more than enough total protein.
And that's really important.
So, there's a paper just out
from Slovenia health-conscious vegans
and these people were consuming
about 1.5 grams of protein per kilo
and the recommendation
is to consume 0.83 grams per kilogram,
that's just for everyday functioning,
not if you're an athlete,
if you're an athlete it's gonna be higher
in the realm of 1.2 grams per kilo
up to sort of 1.6 grams per kilo
But first and foremost,
these populations of people eating only plants
or almost only plants
are getting more than enough total protein.
And then the question is around protein quality
and often people wonder,
"Well, is there a difference in bioavailability as well?"
And you hear about animal protein being much more superior
in terms of absorption
and your body's ability to utilize it.
And of course the RDA and when they did the guidelines,
they had to consider this
because if there was a really, really big difference,
they would need separate guidelines.
0.83 grams per kilo would not be for everyone,
it would be for omnivores
and then for vegetarians and vegans,
there would need to be a separate guideline--
If there was a 20% reduction
in bioavailability of plant protein,
then you would have to increase that up from 0.83.
Yeah, which there's not
and that's based on nitrogen balance studies,
which essentially can look at how well
your body is absorbing protein.
And these studies have been able to compare animal protein
versus plant protein
and see that there is not a big enough difference
to justify different recommendations
for protein requirements for different populations,
omnivores, vegetarians, vegans.
Now, I will say that there have been some studies
where animal protein has been made to look quite superior
to plant protein.
And there are a few problems with this research
or limitations I should say,
there's not a problem with the studies themselves,
but limitations in terms of how we can interpret them.
A lot of this knowledge early on
was built on animal studies, feeding them different proteins
and measuring absorption
and so their physiology is different to us,
but they can act as a useful model particularly pigs,
which have a closer digestive system to us compared to rats.
But one of the biggest problems with this research is that
by and large across the board
when it came to plant protein,
they fed them raw plant protein.
And we know that cooking beans and grains for example,
it helps make the nutrients more bioavailable.
And you and I wouldn't eat a raw bean for that reason
and so what happened is in those studies,
the results sort of overstate the differences
between the animal protein and the plant protein.
Now, in more recent years, there are now human studies
that have looked at properly prepared plant proteins
and in the plant proteins that they've looked at,
there seems to be only a few percent difference
in bioavailability
and there's a paper by Mary Arty from 2019
that summarizes all of that.
And so the current position is that
there might be a slightly lower bioavailability
of plant protein,
but it's much less than what had been thought in the past
and I'll add the caveat there
that there is probably only around six
or seven plant proteins that have been tested,
so I'd love to see more research
and look at hundreds of different sources of plant proteins,
but it does seem like there's not a significant difference
or at this stage reason to be worried
about bioavailability differences.
But perhaps more important than any of this
because let's be honest,
people listening and you and I,
bioavailability and percentages around absorption,
that's not what matters.
What matters is what happens to various health outcomes
or short-term outcomes in terms of strength
and building muscle.
And I spoke before to the clear benefits
of swapping animal protein for plant protein
when it comes to our long-term health.
That there's no doubt about that.
It's absolutely consistent in the literature.
In terms of strength and building muscle,
this is a really interesting area
and there's a lot of emerging science here
and I'm starting to see nutrition scientists in this space
who have been very adamant that animal protein is king
starting to change their tune a bit.
And I don't think it's all sort of said and done,
but there is some early clues
that you can still get the same benefits
in terms of strength and hypertrophy
from consuming plant protein.
And we need more research looking at different populations,
but there's one study
that came out early this year actually
and this was a randomized controlled trial
and really the first of its kind.
A lot of studies in the past Rich
that have looked at plant protein
and looking at resistance training
and measuring strength and hypertrophy
have looked at the addition of say a soy protein shake
to an omnivorous diet
and versus another group who are eating an omnivorous diet
with a whey protein shake.
So, it's very hard to from that study sort of extrapolate
to a completely plant-exclusive diet
because their baseline diet was including animal foods--
They were already meeting their protein needs.
Yeah and they were not a a person consuming a vegan diet.
So, it's just a different question.
Those studies are essentially just comparing
whey versus soy protein
in the context of the two different people
eating the same diet.
I got it.
Whereas with this latest study, it was,
"Let's actually look at healthy adult males
who are consuming a completely plant-based diet,"
same sort of diet you and I would consume,
"with a soy protein shake supplement
against a group consuming an omnivorous diet
with a whey protein supplement."
So, now we have completely plant against an omnivorous diet,
how most people
in the sort of resistance training industry would eat
and we get to see is there a difference in strength
and in terms of hypertrophy, lean muscle?
And I should note these were healthy adults who were active,
but they weren't people
that had been doing resistance training for years.
And there was a very important reason for that selection.
Once you've been training for a very long time,
it's hard to--
Yeah, you plateau.
You plateau, so in a 12 week-trial,
you're not likely to see enough differences
to be able to measure
whether one diet is superior to the other,
so what they wanted is almost these healthy fit people
who are going to get those early, newbie gains.
And I'd see like in this period of rapid growth,
is there a difference between these different diets?
So, they brought these folks in,
they did I think it was 10 or 12 weeks
of resistance training, this is a study out of Brazil.
Hamilton Michels, the lead researcher
and what they found was there was no significant difference
at all in strength or hypertrophy.
And both groups had great improvements in both.
So, look, what can we say from that study?
Well, we can say in healthy adult males
that did not have a history of resistance training,
there seems to be no difference
in terms of whether it's plant protein or animal protein.
Yeah, no difference in terms of your ability to make gains
in a certain period of time.
That's right.
And is that the same for an elderly population
who as you get older, you develop anabolic resistance
and so your ability to generate muscle,
to promote lean muscle growth is harder.?
There are certain ideas out there for example
that animal proteins might be better in that population
because of differences in amino acids
particularly being more concentrated in leucine,
but these were the same ideas
that were held not too long ago about healthy adult males.
And what we're starting to see here
and I didn't mention this about that study,
they set both groups at 1.6 grams per kilogram
of protein intake.
That seems to be the sort of threshold.
If you want to absolutely maximize muscle protein synthesis,
that's the level you need to hit.
Once you go above that,
you don't really see any extra improvement.
So, that's kind of where science is up to today.
Yeah, the current state of affairs.
I mean, that's encouraging
and I would like to see that study
with elderly people as well because I have heard that,
like once you reach a certain age
where your body becomes less able
to hold onto that muscle mass and make those gains
that protein then becomes a much more important component
of your diet.
And that's coming,
those researchers are going to do it,
but having spoken to the researchers
and I think they were a bit surprised
by the results of that study,
I'm not so sure there is confident
going in to studying the elderly now
in terms of animal protein being vastly superior
because in this study of healthy, young adult males,
even though the protein was matched at 1.6 grams per kilo
and they had no differences in strength or in lean muscle,
the plant-based protein group
did consume significantly less leucine.
So, they were still able
to achieve the same health outcomes
despite the lower concentration of leucine in their diet
and I think that's an important thing to consider--
So, what does that tell you?
What do you extrapolate from that?
Well, I extrapolate that there may be an overemphasis
on the importance of dialing into leucine,
I think it's no doubt is important,
but most important is total protein.
And if you're hitting that 1.6 grams per kilogram mark,
I don't think there is added benefit
of just continuing to dial up leucine further and further
and in fact if you speak to longevity scientists,
the likes of Valter Longo that these guys are gonna say
one of the inherent benefits of plant protein
is that it's exposing you
to lower amounts of leucine and methionine,
these amino acids that are thought to activate
not just muscle growth pathways, but also aging pathways.
It's so interesting.
It's also fascinating
to see traditional kind of gym rat bodybuilder type guys
pivoting towards plant-based protein powders
instead of the traditional way.
Like these are not plant-based people,
they're not vegan people,
they're probably eating their chicken and their broccoli
and doing the standard routine,
yet they're still going to the pea and the brown rice
and the various new products that are coming onboard
as opposed to just doing the whey thing
like traditionally they always have.
And some of that is probably down to the way
that whey makes certain people feel
and there's a lot of lactose intolerance out there.
So, it's nice to see that change in the community
and I think this study in particular
is giving people more and more confidence
because people need the data.
There are a lot of great anecdotes out there
and you can see a lot of people like yourself
who have had very, very successful careers
in various forms of performance, the performance world
be it insurance or be it resistance training,
but now to have some actual data
is giving people more confidence to lean into this
and explore a bit further.
So, Simon, I wanna switch gears
and cover some other terrain,
but before we move off of human health,
perhaps some final thoughts on LDL and the carnivore diet
because there's a lot of people out there
who are being influenced
by certain quote, unquote influencers
with respect to this meat heels perspective
of diet and nutrition,
so let's just kind of put this to bed.
So, I am extremely concerned,
I think it would be a nice way of summarizing
what we're seeing with people adopting the old mate diets.
Certainly and I mentioned before that a number of people
in low-carb community have reached out to me
and some of these have been people
that have been eating a completely carnivorous diet
and it cannot be denied
that you can get good short-term results.
Especially if you're moving off
of a standard American diet,
you are gonna experience some pretty immediate changes
in how you feel.
Right and speaking back to that Stanford study
and the microbiome,
it's not sort of far-fetched to understand
that perhaps there is a certain amount
of microbiome disruption where the addition of plant foods
is uncomfortable for people.
And a carnivore diet
essentially it's a strict elimination diet.
And so if these people
even if they're trying to eat healthfully
are introducing certain plant foods
and it's revving up their inflammation and making--
Sorry to interrupt,
but if you've been eating strictly carnivorously,
you're seeding your microbiome
with a certain type of microbiota
that feed on that type of food
and you're lacking the diversity
to be able to create a healthy environment
for the plant microbiomes to propagate
and you'll have digestive issues, you'll have inflammation
and all the like.
Yes, I see it as a bit of a band-aid.
If someone is in a state of chronic inflammation
and their gut is very inflamed,
removing a lot of foods does work,
we see it the low-FODMAP diet for example,
which is a specific diet for people with IBS,
you're removing the triggers.
Now, the problem is the food that you're removing
is not unhealthy,
it's just that your microbiome is not set up
in a way that allows you
to derive the benefits of that food.
So, completely removing those foods from your diet
and doing something like adopting a carnivorous diet,
it could in the short-term make someone feel a bit better.
The problem is because you're removing
all of this prebiotic substrate,
you're starving those bacteria
so you're going to as you say over time,
lose more and more diversity
and you're not getting all of those benefits
that we spoke about before
with regards to the production
of these short-chain fatty acids, these postbiotics
that then keep the gut lining intact
and provide huge benefits both locally in the gut
and also downstream,
these metabolites are lowering the risk
of colorectal cancer.
They're driving down inflammation throughout the body
and protecting us
against things like neurodegenerative diseases.
So, there's a band-aid solution here
where you get this short-term benefit.
What I think is being overlooked is that
chronic diseases have a long latency period.
They bubble away under the surface for a while
and you might experience chronic disease
in your 40s or 50s or 60s, but by and large,
the lifestyle that you were leading 10, 20, 30 years ago
has had a lot to do with the development
of that chronic disease.
You spoke to the soldiers from the Korean War,
they were young,
they were laying down the pathology of atherosclerosis.
So, my fear is this sort of short-term band-aid solution
and my biggest fear with it is that it sends LDL cholesterol
through the roof.
I said before 100 milligrams per deciliter
is like it's considered the kind of recommendation
here in America and in Australia.
But as I said, really you got to get down to 60
or 70 milligrams per deciliter
where you don't see atherosclerosis.
And here's the really, really interesting thing Rich.
Loren Cordain, he wrote "The Paleo Diet" book.
He also published a paper
that goes into what is a healthy LDL cholesterol level,
this is coming from the father of the Paleo diet.
And he went through
and he looked at LDL cholesterols of primates
and of hunter, gatherer tribes
where there is low incidence of atherosclerosis
and his conclusion in this paper that he wrote,
the father of the Paleo diet
was that human LDL cholesterol needs to be at 50
to 70 milligrams per deciliter
in order to avoid atherosclerosis.
So, this is coming from him.
And you might think, "Well, hang on,
he's advocating for the Paleo diet,
then how can he be also saying
that LDL cholesterol should be low?"
And a lot of this comes back down to what the Paleo diet is
versus how people are doing it and so--
That's a very good point
because it's not exactly the way
that it's been massively adopted.
That's right and the Paleo diet
if you look at how Loren Cordain...
What he recommends,
it's talking about meats that are very low in saturated fat.
If you went back and looked in the Paleolithic era
and you look at woolly mammoth
or these types of meats that would have been eaten then,
they are more equivalent to venison in antelope,
which are very low in saturated fat
and higher in polyunsaturated fats.
That's actually ironic in itself
because those people that are blaming polyunsaturated fats
in said oils are overlooking the fact that meat
from the Paleolithic era was very rich
in polyunsaturated fats.
But overall, Loren Cordain,
his recommendations is for a diet
that's low in saturated fat.
Even though he speaks about the inclusion of animal foods,
he talks about that being more consistent
with the quality of meat that people were eating back then
and he talks about the importance of a very high fiber diet.
In fact he mentions that many of these people
were eating over 100 grams of fiber a day.
So, I think that's very important for people to understand
that the Paleo diet was not developed
as this high saturated fat, animal-rich diet.
But the carnivore diet is something altogether different,
it has its roots
in this kind of ancestral ideology I suppose,
but part and parcel of the philosophy of the carnivore diet
is that saturated fat is your friend, we talked about that,
but also these high LDL markers
are something that you should not concern yourself with
because you see a lot of that
because people are having these elevated numbers,
including Shawn Baker who shared it on Rogan et cetera
and in response, they just say,
"Well, that high number isn't relevant
in the traditional way that we've considered it
in the past.
Because I'm doing my diet in this way,
it's somehow buffered
or ameliorated by dint of the fact
that I'm only eating meat," so help me understand
at least like if you were them,
like how you would articulate that
and then let's kind of deconstruct it.
So, I mentioned before that saturated fat,
increasing LDL cholesterol,
increasing risk of atherosclerosis
and coronary heart disease
is the most substantiated relationship in science,
in nutrition science today, without a doubt.
And so much so that in 2017,
a cardiologist by the name of Brian Ferentz,
he co-authored a paper,
which very clearly states that LDL is causal
in the development and progression of atherosclerosis.
There are some very interesting things in that paper
that he walks through and let's quickly go through those.
There is some genetic mutations
that see people with genetically high LDL cholesterol,
heterozygous, familial hyper, cholesterolemia
and homozygous,
hetero if you inherit one of those genes from one parent
and homo if you inherit both,
the latter unfortunately leading
to much more rapid development of disease.
But if you have FH as it's called in short
particularly if it's the homozygous form,
if you're dealt that genetic code
and you have high LDL cholesterol from birth,
these are people that have LDL cholesterol
between 500 and 1000,
which is where we're seeing people
in the carnivore community.
If you are--
Just literally five to 10 to 15 times higher.
I think Paul Saladino is just 700.
700, where Cordain is saying--
50 to 70.
And these people that inherit this,
if they're not treated with statins,
it's very, very common for them
to develop cardiovascular disease in their teenage years
and die in their 20s or 30s.
And that's obviously very, very sad today.
With the progression of statins,
these people are living much longer.
So, that's the first thing that I think is interesting.
The second is that there is a type of science
we didn't discuss it before called Mendelian randomization.
And this is science that really has become I guess popular
or more commonly used in the last five to 10 years.
And thanks to improvements
in our understanding of genetics and--
Mendelian in the Gregor Mendel sense?
I'm not sure--
Do you know Gregory Mendel?
I'm not sure of the origin.
Like the original guy doing plant hybrids
and working in genetics?
Well, it could well be, I'm not sure of the origin,
but what it speaks to is
these studies are like nature's randomized controlled trial.
There are over 50 genetic mutations,
which lower LDL cholesterol.
And if you're dealt that card
and you have lower LDL cholesterol,
you have significantly lower risk
of developing coronary heart disease through your life.
And because this is occurring
as you're being made by your mother,
it is nature's randomized controlled trial.
And so we can see very clearly...
What's really interesting about this is that
these single nucleotide polymorphisms
is what they're called, there's 50 of these or more
is that they all lower LDL cholesterol by different amounts.
But if you are to standardize how much they lower LDL by,
they all have the same order of effect
on coronary heart disease,
which means that it's highly likely
that this is a causal link.
We're talking about true cause and effect.
Between elevated LDL and atherosclerosis?
Yes and it's a linear relationship.
The lower you get LDL cholesterol down
based on whichever genetic variant someone has,
the lower their risk of coronary heart disease.
Now, to add more evidence onto that,
then we have lots and lots of statin trials.
And there's some anti-statin rhetoric out there,
but it's so clear in these studies
that when you lower LDL cholesterol
through the use of either a statin, ezetimibe
or PCSK9 inhibitors, these are different drugs
acting on different pathways that all lower LDL cholesterol.
No matter which one you look at,
they all significantly lower coronary heart disease.
And once you get someone's LDL cholesterol down
to about 70 milligrams per deciliter,
which is 1.8 millimoles per liter with statins
or with PCSK9 inhibitors,
that's where the progression of atherosclerosis stops
and you can start to see some regression.
So, we have evidence from people
who have genetically high LDL cholesterol,
these people if they're untreated
will develop atherosclerosis in their teens,
we have evidence from people who have genetically low LDL,
they're significantly protected against heart disease,
we have the statin trials,
which you see as they lower LDL cholesterol,
you drive coronary heart disease risk down
and then on top of that,
we have all of the observational research.
There's a meta analysis,
the prospective studies collaboration
that included 50 plus studies,
12 million plus person follow up in that study
and it clearly shows in these cohort populations
lower LDL cholesterol lower risk of coronary heart disease.
So, when Paul Saladino with his insanely high LDL says,
"Don't sweat it, don't worry about it.
You don't need to concern yourself with this."
How is he scientifically substantiating that?
I don't think he is.
I think that it's inconvenient for him
that LDL has been shown to be causal
in the development of heart disease
and I've never seen him be able to substantiate that
other than the fact he will say that
his coronary artery calcium score is zero.
But we know
that people with a coronary artery calcium score of zero
can still have atherosclerosis
and can still suffer from a heart attack.
So, for me the evidence is overwhelming.
The lower your LDL cholesterol
and the more years you're exposed
to that low level of LDL cholesterol, the better.
Enough said on that.
I wanna switch gears and explore a couple other things,
we've been going on for a while here.
Obviously there are different motivations and on-ramps
for people who are interested in a plant-based diet
or becoming more plant-predominant in their lifestyle,
we've explored the human health piece
quite extensively today,
but of course there are other motivators,
the ethics of our food choices
and how that implicates planetary health more largely,
which of course also brings up the issue of the environment
and the health implications planetarily
for the choices that we're making
about the foods that we eat
and the food products that we choose to purchase
with our buying power.
So, let's talk a little bit about that.
Maybe start more broadly
with the idea of how these dietary choices are affecting,
like we're in a climate crisis right now.
It's incumbent upon all of us to take greater responsibility
for the choices that we make daily.
How does the plant-based diet figure into this equation
of being more ecologically responsible?
Well, we've turned this place into a giant farm and--
That's my second favorite quote of yours by the way.
And that's had huge effects on greenhouse gas emissions.
Currently agriculture is responsible
for 25% of the world's greenhouse gas emissions.
It's had a huge effects
on biodiversity loss and deforestation.
Agriculture is the number one cause of deforestation
throughout the world
and with that we're losing these precious parts
of the natural world that really are our ally
in fighting climate change.
And it's the single greatest user of freshwater.
Agriculture is resulting in ocean acidification,
it's resulting in the eutrophication and hypoxic conditions
in certain bodies of water that result in the algal blooms
and overall if you are to look at agriculture,
I think one of the most powerful statistics is
50% of the habitable land on earth
is used today for agriculture.
And of that, 83% of that is used for animal agriculture
yet it only returns us with 18% of our calories
and is responsible for two thirds
of agricultural-related emissions.
Yeah, so purely from an academic perspective,
this is a highly inefficient farm that we're running
if the planet is indeed a farm.
Yeah, so we have kind of I guess two parts to this,
the factory farming of animals is very inefficient
because it requires large amounts of land to grow crops
and the feed conversion ratio is not great.
To produce animal products, you have to grow these animals.
And the larger the animal,
the higher the basal metabolic rate.
It's the energy that that animal's burning just to be alive.
And so with that,
what happens is we lose a lot of the calories
that we feed in to the system.
So, if you use like a combustion engine as an analogy,
you put gasoline in
and not all of that energy gets converted
into forward motion of the car,
some of it is cast off by heat, et cetera.
Similarly, when we're taking all of these crops,
we're feeding them to animals,
not all of that is converted into potential energy
that's consumed by humans, a lot of it is lost
like it's just highly high...
If you're an alien who came to earth and and said,
"Show me how you make your food"
and we showed them, they would say this is total insanity.
And food waste is important
and 78% of the world's calories are wasted
and we absolutely have to focus on that
because that's calories that could be ending up in bellies
and it's also a big contributor to greenhouse gas emissions.
But what's overlooked is that the biggest area of food waste
is within animal agriculture, it's the waste of the calories
that we're feeding into this inefficient system.
And to give you an idea of the efficiency
or lack of efficiency, if you feed 100 calories into a cow,
you'll get 40 calories of milk out the other side.
So, you'll lose 60%.
If you feed 100 calories into a chicken,
you'll get 20 calories of eggs out the other side.
So, you're losing 80%.
If you feed 100 calories into a pig or a chicken,
you'll get about 10 calories of meat out the other side.
So, in that example you can think
for one chicken burger,
you could essentially make 10 black bean burgers.
That's the difference we're talking about here
in terms of efficiency and what we're wasting.
And then beef, red meat is the the least efficient of all.
You feed 100 calories into a cow
and you get three calories of meat out the other side.
Now, often when I speak to this, people say,
"Why on the grass-fed beef
and they're not feeding them feed crops,
they're out grazing?"
And that's true,
but the biggest problem with grazing
is the amount of land that it's using.
And in order to make space for that industry,
which provides very few calories,
we have to clear a lot of land.
And there's a really interesting paper from 2018,
Tim searching app that has gone back
and looked at today's grasslands
and at least 41% of them were forests or woody savanna
not too long ago.
And globally right now, still to this day,
the number one cause of deforestation is animal agriculture.
So, I could do a four-hour podcast
on the environmental implications of animal agriculture
and the impact of a pivot to a plant-centric diet
in terms of the ecological impact.
We don't have four hours,
so I wanna focus our remaining time
on the conversation around regenerative agriculture
because I think there's a lot of confusion here.
I've hosted people from this arena on the podcast,
we're both friends with Rylan Engelhardt
who's behind the Kiss the Ground Movement
and the Cafe Gratitude restaurants,
I've had John and Molly Chester
from "Biggest Little Farm" on here,
I have a lot of respect
for people who have devoted their time and energy
towards the regeneration of our soils
because I think this is crucial.
It's a crucial piece in redressing climate change
and pivoting from a consumptive society
into a regenerative one,
but I also think there's a lot of misunderstanding
as I said and also greenwashing
when it comes to how we're understanding
what exactly it is that we're talking about
with respect to regenerative agriculture.
I think there's a lot of well-intentioned,
but perhaps misconceived narratives about this,
so I wanna parse truth from fiction
when it comes to what we're talking about with Region Ag,
what exactly can be accomplished,
what is getting overlooked
and what the kind of inherent flaws are
when it comes to the claims being made
by a holistic land management cohort of advocates.
Gosh, a big question.
So, I am a huge proponent
of regenerative agriculture overall,
I think it makes a lot of sense.
I think that we certainly need to consider soil health.
I think definitions are important here
and also looking at what the science says
because it is an area like the dire wars
where emotion can affect the interpretation of science
and so I think there's a little bit of science
to go through here as well.
Regarding definitions, regenerative agriculture
is really nothing new.
A lot of the practices, be it poly cropping
or intercropping or cover cropping, these are--
Those are ancestral practices,
what is new is industrialized farming.
That's right and so a lot of regenerative agriculture
I guess in some ways it's become a bit of a buzz word,
but I do think it's important
for people to understand the roots
of many of these practices
are from First Nations' land management
and regenerative agriculture overall
is not the same as regenerative beef,
regenerative beef is one practice, this holistic grazing
within a whole plethora
of regenerative agricultural practices.
And so there have been many, many First Nations' people
around the world that have improved soil
without animal integration using poly cropping,
cover cropping, green manure, et cetera.
So, I think that's an important point
because I think sometimes when people think
of regenerative agriculture,
they immediately think of regenerative grazing.
I don't think that there's much debate at all
about poly cropping and intercropping and cover cropping,
I think that's generally accepted across the board
that those practices are much better
for promoting biodiversity and improving soil health.
I think where--
And sequestration.
And sequestration, right.
I think where there is dispute
is around regenerative grazing.
And I believe and I've had enough people on my show
to talk about this as well from both sides--
I should point out so I don't forget,
you've done a number of podcasts with Nicholas Carter,
I don't know, three or four with him,
I mean, those are fantastic.
So, we're not gonna be able
to get into the super nitty-gritty of all these,
but everybody should go listen to Simon's conversations
with Nicolas on his Plant Proof Podcast
because it's very--
You should have him on,
he's an incredible environmental researcher scientist,
but I guess big claims require big evidence.
And there have been some wild claims
made about regenerative grazing over the years,
Allan Savory most notably,
he's well known for a YouTube TED Talk
and he said this was the key to reversing climate change
and his idea is that he believes through his practices
that you can sequester an enormous amount of carbon.
And that would be amazing.
You imagine we could draw down all of this carbon
that has been emitted since the Industrial Revolution,
get it into our soils and cool the planet.
That is a great story.
Now, where does the science lie?
That's ultimately what we should be most concerned with.
And the science doesn't stack up with these practices
being a net carbon sequestering practice.
So, it's true
that you can sequester some carbon, absolutely.
The problem is that when you are accounting
for methane emissions and nitrous oxide from the animals,
the net position is one of greenhouse gas emissions.
And there was a big report done out of Oxford University
called Grazed and Confused by Dr. Tara Gannet
and she walks through this,
the fact that you can probably offset
about 40 to 60% of emissions, but even then over time
what happens is the soil becomes saturated with carbon.
And so over the years,
you're sequestering less and less carbon,
but you still have the same amount of methane
and nitrous oxide emissions
so the practice is becoming less net sequestering over time.
The livestock themselves being the emitters,
but also part of that report was this idea
that the sequestration is not indefinite,
but time-sensitive
in that it's not permanently sequestered in the soil.
That's right.
So it can be reversible.
And still to this day and it is somewhat frustrating,
I actually think that some regenerative grazing
like let's say we were moving to a world
where everyone was adopting very plant-predominant diets
and the only beef production was regenerative grazing,
I think that's a great reserve for the world.
But what I've noticed is from this industry,
there doesn't seem to be a message about reduction,
it seems to be a message about it's not the cow,
it's the how and it's a nice message to the mainstream
who perhaps don't wanna change their meat consumption.
They don't have to,
they can just change where it's come from.
There's an intellectual dishonesty
with advocating for a solution
premised on more grazing without the counterpart
being this is all contingent
upon everybody moving to a more plant-predominant diet
because by dint of sheer land availability,
this model cannot scale to meet global meat demand
as it currently stands.
You're correct in that if everybody pivoted
to only eating beef that was grass-fed
and grazed on regenerative lands such as this,
we would be in a much better state,
but it's a mathematical impossibility
to meet global meat demand using this model.
So, something has to change
and as much as I admire the people
behind "Kiss the Ground"
and what they're trying to communicate,
I think there's a lot of good in that movie,
I feel like it overlooked or gave short shrift
to a very important point, which is that no matter what,
no matter how efficacious this model is,
it will still all demand
that we reduce our meat consumption.
And the key point being here
why do we need to reduce our meat consumption?
Because we need to free up land,
we need to produce more calories from less land
and restore vast amounts of land back to wild ecosystems.
And those wild ecosystems, forests, et cetera
are actually better at sequestering carbon
than a grazed regenerative farm would be.
Yeah, so this is a really interesting point too
because there is this sort of prevailing idea I guess
from people within holistic grazing
that you need the animals to regenerate the land.
And that's not true.
There is a meta analysis 2020,
which specifically looked at what happens to biodiversity
when you include livestock versus excluding them.
And they specifically showed that
when you exclude livestock from land,
you get greater returns in biodiversity,
increased numbers of herbivores,
you restore the predator-prey relationship,
you increase the number of inter vertebrate pollinators,
so I believe that the solution to this Rich is that
until there's an incentive for the landowner
to practice conservation,
like let's think about regeneration
and just drop agriculture off the end of it for a moment.
I understand that farmers
and landowners need to make an income.
And I think the grazing aspect
is a result of economics and--
It's a result of incentives or misalignment of incentives.
And in New Zealand,
they have a an incentive to afforestation,
so converting grasslands into forests
and it's now got to a point so 2020 paper that just...
Or 2021, it's now got to a point where land owners,
the more economical choice is to practice tree planting
in afforestation than livestock grazing.
How did they create that incentive structure?
Well, they are valuing carbon draw down and biodiversity.
And so I think that this is sort of critical
to solving this is our mindset,
if you go back to the First Nations' people,
something that we can learn from their culture
is living in harmony with the environment,
being stewards of the environment,
being guardians of the environment
and it's a different approach to looking at land
and thinking about what value can I extract from that
in the form of calories.
And the New Zealand government what they have done is
they have placed value on the carbon, on carbon storage
and so you create a situation
where the owner of that land stands to make more money
by practicing carbon farming
as opposed to livestock grazing.
We need some fundamental changes from the top down here
as well as from the bottom up
the Farm Bill being one of them.
I know were Island's very active
and doing some advocacy around the next vote
that's taking place I think next year
and we do need a better incentive structure
because these farmers are well-intentioned
and they just wanna make a living
and they're just trying to get by,
so how can we create a system that drives them
towards making that regenerative choice
in a way that's restoring our land, protecting our soils
and promoting the increase in biodiversity?
It always goes back to that analogy with the microbiome,
like these are all micro systems
and macro systems that mimic each other
in terms of how health outcomes are produced
and it starts at the very micro level
and scales up from there.
There is a wonderful documentary
called "Rewilding a Mountain".
You had a hot mountain, it's in Oregon--
Is this in China?
They did something similar in China too,
you wanna talk about that or this is different?--
This is in Oregon I believe, hot mountain.
And it's a documentary
that looked at a 20-year rewilding project.
The land manager at the time consulted scientists
and they said to him, "You have to remove livestock"
and all the riparian areas
which completely damaged the...
The birds had left, the land was very degraded.
A lot of degraded land around the world today
is through overgrazing.
And this documentary steps through what happened.
And you see the pronghorn antelope come back
and that predator-prey relationship comes back
and you see the grasslands grow
and it's not just this kind of mono grassland,
but it's native grasslands and that's an important point,
native grasslands are actually different
to a lot of these grazing grasslands.
They support a very diverse range of herbivores
and so that's a nice I think documentary
for people to watch if they wanna see what happens
when you exclude livestock from the land.
And this is just critical to us
solving the climate change problem in terms of agriculture
is rewilding a lot of land
and producing more calories from less land
and sometimes I hear of this idea of marginal land,
I'm not sure if you've heard of that.
And the idea with marginal land is that this land,
you can't do anything with it except for graze cattle on it.
But that's not true.
That's if you're looking at it
from an extraction of calories lens,
there's nothing marginal about that land
to the animals
and the ecosystem should you regenerate it and--
Marginalized, that's a subjective assessment
only by virtue of how valuable it is to us.
So, I think if we can change that mindset
from a less kind of dominating mindset
and more to practicing conservation and get the incentives
in like New Zealand, this is happening now around the world,
then farmers can be a part, play a key role
in helping to heal the planet.
I would imagine that,
if you can create that sort of structure for these farmers,
just how much more fulfilled
and purpose-driven they would feel
as stewards of the land rather than as extractors.
Well, I think we've gone over three hours, dude.
So much more to say.
I think we did two things on my entire outline,
but I'm not letting you go without congratulating you
on the new book.
This really is like the ultimate primer just chock-a-block
with accessible tools that walk you through
everything that we talked about today and so much more
with respect to how to be more plant-predominant
and understanding all the hows and whys behind it.
I know years of your life went into this,
when I was in Australia that January
you were writing it then
and that seems like a past life, so--
You gave me some great tips actually.
It's finally reached North American shores,
it's coming out September 30, what's the date?
November 1.
November 1, got it.
We've countered this to go out right around the same time.
So, kudos on that,
everybody should check out Simon's podcast, Plant Proof
and beyond that,
plantproof.com is an incredible resource
with tons of articles that are freely available
where you can kind of learn the nuts and bolts
of how to do this properly and everything I might add is
or nothing I should add about Plant Proof
or this book is being monetized by you basically.
This is stuff that you make freely available
and the proceeds of the book are being directed to charity,
am I correct?
Yeah, maybe we should finish this on a nice, optimistic...
I got some good news last night.
What's that?
The Daintree Rainforest in Australia,
which has been threatened through deforestation
over a number of years,
it's the world's oldest tropical rainforest,
one of the most biodiverse places on earth.
And it's a world heritage site now.
And overnight, there was a an agreement made
between the government and the First Nations' people
that are from that area.
And they have been granted the land
to be the custodians of the land,
so it's gonna be handed back to them to be under their care,
the Kuku Yalanji people, eastern Kuku Yalanji people.
So, it's a small win, it's 160,000 hectares zone
that will now be protected under their care
along with all the Kakadu in Australia,
so I woke to that and that's incredible
because that means
this wonderful rainforest will be protected
and their culture can live on
and we're at risk of losing a lot of the culture
from First Nations' people
so I see this kind of agreement as some reparation
making amends for things of the past
and important going back
to what we were talking about earlier
in just creating a societal perspective shift
to one of guardianship and stewardship.
And the more we can integrate
these First Nation cultures back into society, the better.
So, the reason I bring that up
is that you're right,
the proceeds profits of the book will be going...
There are still parts of the Daintree
that are privately-owned
and are under threat of deforestation,
so Half Cut, the organization
led by a friend of mine actually
has half a beard, which--
Oh, yeah, that guy, I know that guy.
What's his name?
Jimmy Halfcut--
Jimmy Halfcut.
Half a bead to represent half the world's--
He sounds like he is "Goodfellas" or something?
Yeah, so half the world's forests have been cleared
and that's what his half beard represent--
Got it.
I've never understood what the symbolic nature of that was.
So, it's a conversation starter.
Whenever I'm out with him, everyone of course comes up
and says, "Hey, dude, what's going on?"
How long has he had half a beard?
Five years I think, yeah, a long time.
He says he's going to regenerate it though.
So, he's regenerating it as we regenerate.
So, I hope that we see a day where he has a full beard,
but he runs the organization HalfCut
that is buying back some of the land around the Daintree,
still part of the Daintree that isn't under world heritage,
but buying it back
and then having it listed on the world heritage
and under the care of the indigenous people
that are from that area.
You're beautiful, man, Simon Hill.
Thank you.
Come back anytime man.
We got plenty more we could talk about.
Yeah, I hope I haven't confused people.
I think you've cut through a lot of confusion
and created clarity from my perspective.
More clarity again can be found in Simon's book,
"The Proof Is In The Plants", plantproof.com.
On Instagram, Simon is constantly sharing
super helpful information @plant_proof
and you're on Twitter a little bit,
you mix it up that's once in while--
Am an avid Twitter user,
I don't have many followers on there--
It's a good time, I always check in
like you're not afraid to scrap it up a little bit
with the--
I wondered actually, does Rich watch this?
Oh, yeah, oh, dude, I watch from the sidelines,
I don't participate--
I have a standard copy and paste line
which is "Can you provide a study that supports this claim?"
And tell you what, my strike rate is not great,
I get barely any replies to that line.
That's the conversation ender?
Yeah.
There you go.
There are some people who of course can engage
in a civil conversation but--
Yeah, but three or four tweets
and it generally devolves into less civil,
but we kept it civil here today--
We did.
And civil in the world
and enjoy the rest of your time in LA
and we'll do this again soon.
Rich, love you, brother.
Thank you so much for having me.
And if you find yourself in Bondi,
Bondi Beach where Simon hails from,
you got to visit in Simon's restaurant--
And I can't take the credit,
I can't take all the credit for that, I need to--
Well, Tania.
Tania, my lovely partner,
she's made that the place that it is
so of course if you're in town come on down.
Yeah, for sure.
Best plant beast eats in all of Sydney
right there in Bondi Beach,
when I was spending time there that was my second home
and next time you're gonna have to let me pay for a meal
because--
No, we love to have you.
It was great.
So, thanks, man.
Much love, talk to you soon, peace, plants.
(bright upbeat music)